hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and i'm
just checking in on you
to see how your week is going is it
going as wonderful as mine
oh jesus what a [ __ ] week you know a
few weeks ago
i went to the penn state game
they were playing ball state i think
you know they had to cover a lot of
points so i'm there with versi you know
let's throw some money on the game
let's have a good time you know you know
the spread's going to be big when the
flyover is helicopters
[Music]
you know it's a big game if you actually
get a stealth bomber but if you get two
[ __ ] helicopters that don't quite get
there by the end of the [ __ ] song
that's when you know the spread is
double digits all right this is for
gamblers here all right so
and the home of the
brave hooray
thousand one thousand two thousand three
thousand four
yay
um i found out afterward that uh
everybody i was with was disappointing
that that it wasn't jets but they knew
that i flew you know
a helicopter you know so they didn't
want to
it's like i get it
i got 300 hours you don't have to
[ __ ]
[ __ ] look at me like i fly for the
news i don't give i'm not it's a hobby
i'm not getting offended by that
you know
there was some hack out there you know
telling awful jokes that we've seen
for a bunch of years and you were
laughing and i would be offended by that
because i do that
for a living you cannot get
offended if somebody steps on the toes
of your hobby
i don't know if that's a rule that's a
rule in my world i don't i don't want to
hear about your [ __ ]
you know what's funny about a hobby
is this is how much you know that how
much people hate their [ __ ] jobs
is like
have you ever heard
the level of passion in somebody's voice
about their job
the way they talk about their [ __ ]
hobby
you know what i mean like if some guy's
into like
some guy's into fishing like bobby kelly
did
if you're into like fishing okay i don't
give a [ __ ] what those guys do
for a living okay just pick the funnest
[ __ ] job ever at the end of the day
no matter how fun your job is it becomes
a [ __ ]
job
time to make the donuts no matter what
it is
you know even my fun job
the job's still fun but oh getting there
the older you get oh the older you get
you know
you start seeing those glow sticks lax
and your bottom lip starts quivering
like
how long is it going to take me
to get from these glow sticks to the
entrance and from the entrance
through that line of cattle
in which
i am part of that livestock how long
how long has this been going on how long
is this gonna [ __ ] take
you know what i mean
however
i gotta tell you just a few times i
actually fly
to go on a vacation which is very rare
because i always got a gig
you know what i mean
i always i always do a gig when i'm out
there to pay for everything
so i keep my head above the water
because there's no 401k when it comes to
being a comedian you're on your own
i ain't dying like larry fine in a
[ __ ]
where the [ __ ] they put him talking to a
wall i don't know if he died like that
but you know he could have died better
he's one of the three stooges
he would have been a hundred and [ __ ]
18 years old
the other day if moe didn't slap him
around so much you want to talk about a
[ __ ]
uh uh cte case
larry fine
larry i'm not fine
thank you very much moe
sorry these are three stooges references
from the [ __ ] 1940s um anyway um
yeah the level of [ __ ] passion
somebody has when they talk about that i
don't give a [ __ ] they could be the
whittling
you know you know whatever i started
watching on youtube i don't know how i
got into this these this [ __ ] guy has
a lathe
that's right a lathe
i've seen every animal kill every other
animal i've seen every person get hit in
the balls as much as they could get hit
in the balls i've seen every month of
every fail for the last [ __ ] i don't
know 15 years
i've seen every resto mod
every every restoration every [ __ ]
i don't know what do you call those what
do you call those cars that they they
build but they they don't actually put
them out to the public
those uh um ah what do they call those
[ __ ] things whatever
it'll come to me
it'll come to me concept car a concept
car seen all of those [ __ ] things
now i am down to i am watching this guy
that has a lathe
for those of you who don't give a [ __ ]
about woodworking or anything like that
i believe that's what it's called it's
that thing you know where you stick a
piece of wood on it and it's you know
you
stick the point in on either end and it
spins it these guys take what look like
files that you would use to to get out
of jail
back in the day right
and um
he whittles the [ __ ] thing into
something like a piece of art or
something
a lot of vases this guy makes
and uh i just i don't know i just
started watching that that's just one of
those things right
like if you had the you know i don't
give a [ __ ] what job you had like the
president of the united states
you don't have to sit in traffic i mean
the downside is you get blamed for
everything but you don't have to sit in
traffic
somebody writes your speeches you just
go up there and you try to say it with
an earnest look on your face
i did not
have sexual relations
with that woman right he just [ __ ]
you know thousand points alike
i'm the decider
oh
whatever the [ __ ] obama said
then you had donald trump who was just a
jazz he's a jazz singer he was just up
there [ __ ] improv
people looking at the teleprompter and
looking at each other like what the [ __ ]
is he talking i don't know man
he's on one
he's playing in free time right
and you got this guy here forgetful
freddy you know i don't even know what
he can't even
i don't know that guy
jesus christ he sounds like he's just
always telling
the most boring story ever that has no
point and he's just so old and cute you
don't want to get up and walk out of the
room so i just try to avoid him
um
what is my point so if you're [ __ ]
president and you're dealing with that
[ __ ] all day right and now your wife's
the first lady so god knows you know
she's pushing to do something
you know
which i thought was the new move
with barack's wife and bill clinton's
wife like they got all up in there like
they [ __ ] got elected too
you know what i mean they're making tick
tock videos and [ __ ] it's just hey let's
settle down ladies you didn't win the
election
i i i noticed
you know
bush trump and now joe biden like their
wives are just like yeah man you know
i'm [ __ ] cool just chilling here in
the background which i gotta tell you
that's the kind of first lady i would be
i would just be sitting there you know i
gotta be honest with you this is the
kind of [ __ ] i am i would literally
just be enjoying the perks
that [ __ ] st i don't have a pet
project what's my pet project
[ __ ] swimming in the pool
utilizing that personal chef
why yes i would like another slider
then all i got to do is get dolled up
whenever my [ __ ]
other half is i would i would crush as
the first male first lady
i would [ __ ] crush i would be like
p90x and are doing the elliptical
i would be in savage
[ __ ] shape
you know
i wouldn't call attention to it i just
try to see
how many speeches it took before people
started knowing that i was getting
[ __ ] chiseled that would that would
be the game within the game
for me as the first male first lady
you know
typical [ __ ] women man
you got a great gig and you're looking
across the table and all you see is the
roses you just think somebody's got a
better that guy's got dead bodies on his
[ __ ]
brain every night
dead babies and all of this [ __ ] from
[ __ ] missiles that didn't land where
they were supposed to land this guy's
aging in [ __ ] dog years
and they still look across the table and
think he got it better
that is the genius
of of being happy with where the [ __ ]
you i would be so i would just be like i
know the perspective is different
because you know we only let women out
of the kitchen like 30 years ago or at
least that's the level that white women
are complaining right now
um
i get it so they feel like they have to
[ __ ] climb
the hill
you know what i mean but i would have to
say
that even if tables were flipped and
women were running [ __ ] and i was in a
position to further position
further the position of men i'd have to
go anti-vaxxer there
and just think for myself
[Music]
i'm doing what's best for me [ __ ]
everybody else that's
that's the [ __ ]
the group this is about me that's that's
the kind of male first lady i would be
oh man i would i would i would get into
paul newman's shape and i would [ __ ]
rip off that guy's wardrobe i'd be
[ __ ] cardigan sweaters when i didn't
have to wear a suit
okay
i would look
like a man that knew somebody that was a
member of a tennis club
all right
savage [ __ ] shape and i would just i
would you know have the secret service
sound proof one room and i would just be
playing drums all day i'd probably slip
off the wagon
you know
you know you're like [ __ ] stevie
wonder and [ __ ] coming over the white
house whenever you want
i mean you can't you know at some point
somebody's going to come by with
something and i'm going to be after a
while you probably get bored
this is when you know you're the
ultimate freeloader when you're praying
i'm praying that my wife gets elected
again not because i feel it's good for
the country is i just don't want to give
up the perks
you know what i mean
because even if my wife goes out and
does the [ __ ]
speech tour
you know give speeches to the [ __ ]
bankers
that you know she did exactly what they
told her to do so she wouldn't have a
convertible ride in dallas and we ended
up with the mansion in martha's vineyard
still you know what i mean it's like
you're on the other side of it
your songs are no longer on the charts
the casinos you're playing every year
get further and further out into the
woods
and now you gotta go back to sitting in
traffic i don't know how
i think that that's why the rolling
stones still tore
after hearing steve gorman's story of
their police escorts
to and from the arenas that they play i
mean why would you ever go back to
civilian life
i mean you live on a planet with close
to eight billion people and you never
sit in traffic
and you travel the world i mean that is
[ __ ]
amazing
[ __ ] amazing
that's the way to do it so yeah i don't
know why these first ladies some of them
they just want to [ __ ]
busy up their goddamn day put your feet
up
you're in the white house anything you
want
you can literally look through your
record collection and anybody who's
still alive will come over to your house
and play for you because they want to go
over there
what do you want to do tonight i don't
know i don't have a club sandwich maybe
have ac dc
play an acoustic set
you know have a couple of pints with
brian and i'm gonna call it an evening
what are you doing
trying to decide whether or not we're
gonna bomb this country and go to war
that sucks for you sweetheart
you want a foot massage
um
that's how i do it
that is exactly the way old freckles
that's how i play the white house
[ __ ] tipping the the the
maybe hanging out with the [ __ ]
secret service
smoking sticks with them don't worry no
way i won't tell nobody
this it keeps me calm which keeps the
president calm so this is part of your
duty to hang out here and have a cigar
on the back porch at the [ __ ] white
house
sure it's not that simple um anyway but
as i mentioned i am having a great week
so i ended up winning like 75 bucks i
don't bet big okay
my head might be big my head is big
my bets are small
so i um
i won 75 bucks on that
and uh
you know so that's just out there right
it was through verzi's [ __ ] context
you know he's sicilian he knows a lot he
knows a lot of people
um
so anyways the yankees were playing the
red sox
as i predicted
as i predicted back in august
the red sox regardless of how bad they
were playing
they played nothing but the dregs of the
league for the rest of the year except
for a series against tampa and against
yankee the yankees we got our asses
kicked on both but i said if it comes
down to a one-game playoff playoff
right
it is anybody the [ __ ] orioles could
have beat the yankees one game playoff
or beat the red sox it's one
[ __ ] game this isn't football
with football the man wins
for the most part every [ __ ] week
right with baseball
you know baseball is equal opportunity
and any given [ __ ] day the worst team
in the league can beat the best team it
can just happen so the yankees [ __ ]
we owned them in the beginning they
owned us
in the end and swept us
gave us the o right there fred i believe
in our own [ __ ] stadium
so i'm sitting there thinking like i
kind of like that
i would much be rather be the team
that got swept
than to be the sweeper when there's a
one game playoff if we're going into a
series i like that better because you're
getting actually c like a match up like
a one game playoff is it's not a playoff
that's why march madness
is so mad
you know it's one game and you [ __ ]
come out cold next thing you know says a
[ __ ] 16 c beats a [ __ ] number one
uh we get a bill we watch sports so
i was like you know even though i know
we're not going anywhere
it'd be [ __ ] cool to end the yankee
season
pay him back we're finally even
we're finally even with the new york
yankees as far as playoffs go
we had a one-game playoff with them in
1978 they beat us we just beat them
okay that takes that off the books
all right
we lost a five-game series to them
in 1999.
when pedro threw the late great don
zimmer he just sort of you know he laid
him down to the ground
we lost that we beat them in a five-game
series in 2018.
they beat us in a seven-game
heartbreaker in 2003. we beat him the
next year in a seven game so we are now
even
with that we broke their hearts equally
in the playoffs
all right we'll never catch their
championships but it's nice you know
we're whittling away at it
we'll see we'll see what happens so
um
and now what i love i love that tampa
bay has kicked our ass the whole [ __ ]
year so we're going in there we're
supposed to lose
so you just walk in there
fat dumb and happy next thing you know i
[ __ ] won a game we're gonna win
another game i remember talking to
somebody
i was on the road
and i talked to a former edmonton oiler
and he was talking about i think in 1980
or 81
no 1980
canadians were in the midst they'd won
76 77 78 and 79 they were the team to
beat and then the upstart edmonton
oilers came in
which i put up there with the [ __ ]
1970s steelers as far as like who they
drafted and what they just it just
doesn't happen
you know
wayne gretzky mark messier yari curry
paul coffey grant fury i mean they were
kids and they were all
destined to be hall of famers
with their name all over the cup so they
played him in 1980 in the playoffs so
one of these guys in edmonton was i
would go what were you thinking when you
got there and he said
he got oh we didn't think we were going
to win we just
we couldn't [ __ ] believe we were
playing him because we were kids
and one of the stories he told me
was that when gay lafleur would start
winding up at the forum
you know and coming up the ice
he said the whole [ __ ] forum would be
would be going
cheering his name and he said when he
would skate by they were doing it too
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's how
that's how [ __ ] young they were and
that's how they were like literally two
years removed from just being [ __ ]
fans of the nhl if not one year and now
they're playing in it against like um
their heroes let me see i think they've
swept them
1980 edmonton
versus
montreal
resort which is a prediction
um edmonton oilers
wait a second this is december 13th no
playoffs playoffs
maybe it was 80 81.
let's see playoffs
talk myself into a corner here all i
know is they won how about that can i
just tap out on that
they displayed much more poise and
purpose than judges of the unflappable
198 preliminary round edmonton versus
montreal
edmonton won six to three three to one
six to two and that was it oh it's best
three out of five they swept them
six three
three one
six two
go [ __ ] yourself the first two games
um
i believe
they might have been in montreal
unreal
so there you go goes back to the uh
the red sox hopefully
i mean that's
not quite the same thing as far as a
bunch of kids but who can't we what the
[ __ ] do we got to lose we got nothing to
lose so we we shall see what's happening
i won't see what happens
because i'm in the midst of getting
ready for this [ __ ]
check right i got here so we'll see how
it goes i don't know about this one guys
i passed the other one so i don't know
about this one this one this is a la
ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha
[ __ ] this is a lot of [ __ ] i might have
to pass this in segments i will get it
done by the end of the year and as long
as i do gives a [ __ ]
so i'm going in there i'm having a good
time
um who's getting new that's all [ __ ]
i want to make this [ __ ] happen
um so
oh my god dude if i [ __ ] pass this
thing if i pass this thing i got my
special i got my rating i'm [ __ ] f is
for family
is wrapped
i i like my i have nothing to do
except play with my kids
this is the dream
this
is the dream man tell my [ __ ] jokes
around the world and occasionally wait
for some cool acting gig to come in i am
in the sweet spot thank you and the
dismount
i'll tell you he has a handsome first
lady that bill burke oh man i would love
that i gotta get my wife to run for
president
you know i think it's time
now is the time for the first
female person what if my wife came out
of nowhere
and beat the uh
kamala harris
i was gonna say the vice president not
the kamala harris like the ohio state
university
um that is her name right i don't
[ __ ] know i have no idea i don't pay
attention you know what i'm proud of it
i'm proud of it i am proud
i don't want to watch somebody looking
like he's given a [ __ ] book report
on some book he didn't want to read or
didn't really read i just can't i mean
we've been dealing with that there's not
been a good speech given since [ __ ]
obama trumps were horrific
biden's i i don't know what they are i
mean they they should have been they
should be uh i don't
i don't know what they should be
categorized
as fireside ramblings oh bill come on
man can't you be a little nicer to the
fella he's just an old fella dude by the
way what is the [ __ ] deal last two
the last two presidents combined are
like a hundred and [ __ ] 90 years old
um
all right so
so i'm watching this person whittle
and um
also i've been watching this guy because
i've been you know
finally progressed past you know my
shoulders being [ __ ] up and now i i
found this thing i saw this woman at the
gym doing like these back bends i'm like
why the [ __ ] do you get that limber so i
just looked it up
and i found this guy in like a yoga mat
and he's showing how to stretch out your
upper back and i got to tell you dude it
is
uh it is about as a feminine a position
as you could be
but i was sitting there going like but
wait a minute if you are that [ __ ]
flexible i won't [ __ ] my shoulders up
again i'll be doing this even said one
of the stretches you'd probably be too
embarrassed to do this at the gym it's
basically all variations of like doggy
style doggy style up against the wall
it's really
really submissive
[Music]
uh to be done in the garage not in front
of your wife um anyway um how about the
chargers versus the radius great game
the other night and uh i got to be a
dosh
i got to be a douche here i tweeted
about it one of the guys in the
announcer we all make mistakes so i'm
not saying this guy doesn't know what
he's doing
but when he was talking about how many
raiders fans there were versus charger
fans he goes raider fans were like hey
we were here first
and oh
i was like not so fast
broadcaster sir
that is not true
the los angeles chargers
formerly the san diego chargers a lot of
people forgot including that man in the
booth that before
they were formal they would dig los
angeles charges formerly san diego
chargers formerly the los angeles
chargers yes in 1960
[Music]
first year
the first year of the afl
they played one year
in los angeles now i know a lot of
writing fans like oh yo big [ __ ] deal
only one year it wasn't about amount of
years
he said who was first
stick with the jargon
stop trying to worm your way out of it
um
raider radius fans came out in force and
they played they were wearing one of my
favorite uniforms in sports the raiders
white jersey with the silver number is
the best [ __ ] professional nfl
football uniform ever
ever
and you know the universe always
balances itself which is why when you
look at their fan base so many of them
are dressed up like they're in the
pirates of the caribbean the musical i
don't know what is going on
with their fans i wouldn't [ __ ] with any
of their fans but i got to be honest
with you
you know not like i'm a fashionista here
but i i you know i i they look like
they're going to a [ __ ] halloween
party
um i don't know why people think that
that is intimidating
[Music]
to dress like uh
i like your i like the flare of your
character what's your character's name
um
anyway and shout out to charger fans
for not dressing like different like
weather like clouds and then someone
else is a [ __ ] lightning bolt now you
know goddamn well somebody did that you
know goddamn well somebody did
um all right
anyway let me do a little bit of the
reeds here let me do a little bit of the
reeds here
all right here's my manly moment of the
day today i was [ __ ] landing
a helicopter and it was between
and where my little helipad was was
between an a-star and an r-22 both of
them
were getting ready to take off so the
main road is a [ __ ] spinning
and my instructor's like you think you
can get in between there and i was like
yeah
and i did it
and i set it down i felt like such a
[ __ ] badass
secretly knowing that i wasn't
but knowing the perception of someone
that watched me do that were like man
that guy
that guy's cool man
that guy never questions
the decisions he makes
oh jesus
i i will never be that guy
you know
i questioned everything i did in the
last 20 minutes
for the next 20 minutes and then i
questioned that 20 minutes ago why did i
just waste that 20 minutes thinking
about the previous 20 minutes that's
where i'm at all right romans everybody
you know most guys have tried different
ways to last longer but thinking about
baseball doesn't always work
oh this means you jizz too quick
the folks at roman
and online men's health company
are changing the game with roman swipe
why can't you just talk your way out of
that
and just be like listen this is how
excited i am to be a father
i want it to happen yesterday now the
secret to longer lasting sex roman
swipes are clinically proven our
clinically proven way to last longer in
bed they're effective easy to use and
fast acting but don't require
prescription another way it could go hey
it's not my fault i'm i'm in touch with
my body
you know i know what i like i know what
i got to think about
you know
i'm living my best life my orgasms are
for me
roman can ship swipes to you in discrete
i thought that's it in the desert in
discrete unmarked packages
and each swipe's packet
is small enough to hide in your wallet
for whenever you need it
do they have like different size swipes
for depending on how hot you think the
girl is
um
smoking hot chick
you literally got a face cloth just
covered from your navel all the way down
to your knees and then if she's you know
some battle axe you know what i mean you
just got like a uh
it's like you tear a quarter off a
kleenex um
swipes are great they will not transfer
to your partner so you can last longer
without worrying they're super easy to
use just take the swipes out of the
packet swipe it on let it dry and you're
good to go that's it
do they have different size swipes for
different size dicks
um
what if you got one of them [ __ ]
monster hogs you know what i mean like
what's your overhead on this do they
have like bigger ones for that for the
guys who get the uh what are those will
those condoms called that i never had to
buy
the magnums
the magnums the meat hammer the [ __ ]
uh horse [ __ ]
trojans uh go to
getroman.com get ten dollars off your
first order of swipes plus free two-day
shipping that's
getroman.com for ten dollars off your
first order of swipes plus free two-day
shipping
if yankee fans want to last longer they
can think of that one game playoff last
oh cheap shot cheap shot sorry you got
you know which i'll never forget because
that's all they can say now we did stuff
before
headspace everybody
wouldn't it be wouldn't it be great if
there were a pocket sized guide that
helped you sleep slash focus slash act
slash be better it's gonna make you a
better actor
uh there is and if you have 10 minutes
headspace can change your life man next
please mention all of the talking points
below well that's pretty hostile for a
[ __ ] meditation app all right relax
next thing you know you're gonna tell me
g will you jesus and then we're gonna
move to central america and i gotta
drink the [ __ ] juice with you
headspace man
is your daily dose of mindfulness man
in the form of guided meditation man in
an easy to use at
headspace man
is one of the only meditation apps
advancing the field of mindfulness man
and meditation through clinically
validated research baby so whatever the
situation man headspace man really can
help you feel better man
overwhelmed
take a chill pill man headspace has a
three-minute sos meditation for you need
some help falling asleep yes headspace
has a wind down session their members
swear by
and for parents
do they have a block out your wife's
reality tv [ __ ] on the flat screen
[ __ ] sos app and for parents
headspace even has morning meditations
you can do with your kids
you can meditate with your kids jesus
christ headspace is bad do you beat your
kids they're afraid are they going to be
quiet i can't get my kids my kids
my kids look at me like i'm i'm one of
the rides at a [ __ ] playground
jumping on my neck you know today i was
laying there had my eyes closed my
daughter leapt up in the air and landed
like
hulk hogan's finishing move right on my
[ __ ] not even my chest half stomach
she got all the rib cage
oh the noise i made actually made her
cry she thought she broke me
i just went i went oh
oh sweetheart buddy you can't do that oh
you can't do that you can't do that
but how scary it was seeing your parents
get hurt
you thought they were invincible anyway
headspace man it's backed by 25
published studies on its benefits
yeah this is great man meditating from
what i heard
if i could [ __ ] slow down i would do
this 600 i actually i did do this for a
while like usual i got too [ __ ] busy
i gotta do it again six hundred thousand
five star reviews and over 60 million
downloads
headspace wait a minute
that's one in every ten thinks it's
[ __ ] great is that right
no
one in every hundred five star okay
headspace makes it easy for you to build
a life-changing meditation practice with
mindfulness that works for you or your
schedule anytime anywhere you deserve to
feel happier man headspace is meditation
made simple go go to headspace.com
that's headspace.com
for a free one-month trial i have this
on my phone when i use it i feel better
i act better i'm a better person for
some dumb reason i should do it again
with access to headspace full library of
meditation for every situation you can
think of
this is the best deal offered right now
head to headspace.com
today
they even have a [ __ ] meditation for
when you get a swipe that's too small
for your dick
and she's the hottest chick you've ever
seen that guy will talk you just the
sound of his male voice will make you
come later
um
all right where the hell are we is that
the end of the podcast i believe it is
well look at that it's the end this is
the end
my only friend friendly and now the
tampa bay devil race you got to be
rooting for them for that city to sweep
all the championships unless you're a
red sox fan
who's kidding who it's tampa all right
they need
they need something good to happen
all right they're tampa
all right
l ron hubbard had a boat dock there okay
they need
help
they need this all right so i'm rooting
for them but not against the red sox but
i'll root for other than that um all
right that is it um
and now before we end the podcast
uh we have my nfl chat of the week
with the one and only paul verzi
from it's a little excerpt from our uh
actually he's not an excerpt it's uh
something that we do for bet
uh mgm
and last week me and paul verzi slapped
that casino around going three and one
each we went six and two against the
spread
so uh what does that tell you
only the lucky we got lucky last week um
actually versus having a good year i'm
not having a good year gambling but uh
here we go you can listen to our picks
for next week listen to them bet against
us keep score do whatever you want a
couple of meatheads talking football
here we go what's up everybody and
welcome back to the anything better nfl
week five preview
okay uh and the offer guys it's an
amazing offer by bet mgm as you all know
by now we've teamed up with bet mgm
this season we'll be using bed mgm lines
to make all of our picks
we'll have special offers for our
listeners every week okay if you haven't
signed up for bet mgm yet use bonus code
burr b-u-r-r you'll get a hundred
dollars free after placing your first
one dollar bet here's how it works you
download the bet mgm app and you sign up
using the bonus code burr b-u-r-r place
your first dollar money line bet on any
game you'll receive a hundred dollars in
free bets immediately after placing your
bet regardless of the outcome of the bet
just make uh make sure you use bonus
code burr uh when you sign up so you're
gonna get a hundred dollars man right
there um on uh on on your bets so make
sure you sign up that is b-u-r-r
all right guys here's what went down
this week
uh everybody was was you guys are really
jumping on what me and bill's picks are
some are some are betting what i'm
betting some are betting what bill's bet
and but both of us managed
both of us managed this week to go three
and one which when you're picking four
games in the nfl that's damn good means
we went uh you know means we went six
and two
together we're still we're still not
quite at 500 or maybe right there i
think you're at 500. but i got to tell
you something i'm too i'm two games
under i was looking at four and oh and
the tomb brady buccaneers
i was dead
i'm going oh my god i'm going i am i'm
going i'm 2-0
and now the 49ers are winning by seven i
might go four and oh bill is screwed
bill is screwed then i look at bill's
picks because andrew sent them to me and
i go oh my god he's three and oh my god
he's three you know and then you had the
fourth game on which was really one of
the best games of the week that's sunday
night game man and i got to tell you
something i give the patriots credit to
have that 56-yard attempt in the reign
hit the [ __ ] thing they almost won
that game um great you know there was a
couple people sent me tech score what do
you think of that call they should have
gone for it it's just like
what it's a 56 yarder
it's the end of regulation go ahead and
go kick the [ __ ] thing he kicked it
long enough it just hit the goddamn
upright if that thing falls in tom brady
it takes a year off his life
if that thing falls in dude i'll tell
you this when you when you have when
you're betting the [ __ ] when you your
team kicks a field goal and it hits the
step [ __ ] upright with those
microphones you never forget that sound
i always thought it was like plastic
no it's dude i got to give you credit
where credit's due
i loved love not only did i i love that
you won it i loved your buffalo bills oh
you know me a 17 i mean who loves a deep
favorite like me and then having a cover
because you know my sayings on favorites
guys they did what they were supposed to
do and they put up 40 on them i know the
fact that you loved it i made me nervous
because paul versi nobody
predicts a bloodbath
if you're a meteorologist what's the
weekend going to be like oh it's going
to be a bloodbath nothing but rain
six foot of snow uh i thought it was
gonna happen every you do you see a
nor'easter every [ __ ] weekend
my thing i got outside of what it is
that i do paul that's why i'm having a
tough year here
all right two things i did i'm [ __ ] i
got the kids now so i'm i'm i'm not
paying attention the way i need to as a
degenerate gambler and then number two
i'm taking favorites like a [ __ ]
idiot all right well all my underdogs
paul all my underdogs have been winning
take the points
there's no excuse
no we're we're in the deep end now
there's no excuses first of all paul i
had a better week than you
huh i had a better week than you
what do you mean because we went head to
head on san francisco and [ __ ]
seattle here's how you had a better you
went head-to-head paul paul we went
head-to-head and i told you seattle i
said sneaky pete's going to come in
there sneaky pete's going to come in
there and they're going to [ __ ] win
and all sneaky pete with his letterman
sweater looking like some guy he can
trust came in he dropped their [ __ ]
panties
gave him the old house you [ __ ] you
know what he ran out of there with the
victory and here's the type of friend
that i am okay here's what i'm here's
the [ __ ] guy that you're friends with
okay don't dislocate your elbow pat
yourself on the back okay what do we got
here
congratulations on knocking my yankees
out it hurt it hurt you won 75 bucks
because we bet 75 bucks
you want the cycle on you paul we beat
you guys in a seven game series a five
game series in a one game series there's
no other way we can beat you in october
so you guys have to win the next time
or else we're lapping you now yeah well
did you ever think a red sox fan could
talk to you like this paul this is what
i'm saying and this is what sucks is i
came in like a gentleman and i [ __ ]
gave him no you didn't i said
congratulations
[ __ ]
you [ __ ] yankee [ __ ] this is what
you guys this is what you do when you
lose
i said come on i'm really happy for you
guys i just want to put my tie on and
say congratulations you're trying to get
out of this [ __ ] talk no no no i'm not a
[ __ ] let me tell you something paul let
me tell you something i
know you as a sports fan i remember when
the giants beat the patriots the first
time you were like yeah you rammed it up
your [ __ ] answers i remember all of
that [ __ ] you said i didn't say it like
you absolutely said that i was standing
in tom papa's living room another giant
fan i had it in [ __ ] stereo i don't
listen to a guy who makes bread give me
[ __ ]
we were barely friends i didn't even
know you then it was like our first
barely friends yeah we was like wow oh
607. wow
i didn't know you we had two
conversations so what so you don't know
me so then you're a [ __ ] and then this
was who's this new phony guy i met oh i
was a [ __ ] mid-20s dope i'm happy
that you i'm not happy i remember regis
philbin regis philbin rest his soul when
the red sox came back and won in 2004 he
goes well he's like that's where these
red sox sets you know you won get over
it okay
and just completely ignored that you
guys chanted 1918 in our faces
so much so that everyone in the league
was doing it to us you got
the whole [ __ ] time look at your eyes
you know it's true and then you [ __ ]
lose and then you as pete coryelli would
say you're running hard i i was i was
gonna say it was a good read just you
did i mean i'm just
i was gonna say it was a good regis you
did i'm full of compliments listen paul
anyway you had a better week you had a
better week don't get used to it okay
because listen cause listen listen i
went three and one two we're right neck
and neck no no no no paul no no let's
let we went head to head on a game
okay we faced each other paul
we happened okay at arthur ashe stadium
we both came out with that little bookie
visors on and we went out there and we
picked a [ __ ] game i know what you're
trying to do i just figured it out i
just figured you out you're trying to
get me and it's oh it's working you're
trying to get me to want to beat you and
talk a little [ __ ] okay okay you want it
to stir the fire let's go i got first oh
paul's paul's looking for someone right
now minus 18.
[Laughter]
all right what the [ __ ] back up the
truck this is the pic paul you're going
to beat me this week i'm going to tell
you why because i haven't even [ __ ]
looked at these things yet no uh andrew
i know you've been studying like like
the you know paul you know if you
applied yourself in other areas of your
life the way you do with your gambling i
swear to god
andrew can you scroll i can't i need
that should be stained by now i'm gonna
say that this would be and every time
i've said the lock it's been wrong but
i'm gonna say this is my lock of the
week
okay
urban meyer
and the jacksonville jaguars have had a
disastrous week
urban meyer was in a bar
chick is dancing all over them
she gets no [ __ ] nobody nobody says
anything about the guy that filmed it
the [ __ ] rat okay go ahead yeah the
guy's filming it he's sitting there the
whole deal apparently urban meyer then
apologizes to the team doesn't fly with
them stays in and gets caught out with
family and then out drinking again
doesn't fly with his own team to me that
says disarray and the tennessee titans
are coming he went out boozing again he
went out boozing again dude dude that is
that is 1970s raiders football what are
you talking about jacksonville jaguar's
owner made him say he needs to earn
respect back i mean the the organization
is in disarray they're winless and the
tennessee titans lost a heartbreaker to
the jets i am taking the tennessee
titans minus four to the [ __ ] bank
okay i think you're totally reading it
wrong paul
okay
well i think the owner is saying what
people want him to say
he needs to earn the respect of the
players what are they going to get 50
tim tebows there
look urban meyer went out and did what
half of them are doing every [ __ ]
weekend they don't give a [ __ ] well i'm
just saying i think if you don't fly
with your team after a loss that says a
lot and because you're still out there
boozing chasing ass
yeah
yeah while your [ __ ] linebacker's
sitting there [ __ ] hurting put
putting em's body out there for you
you're out of the [ __ ] hooters [ __ ]
him players aren't interested in that
[ __ ] him i'm taking the tennessee titans
with my first pick i think you're out of
your [ __ ] mind all right let's go to
head-to-head they're laughing they're
saying he's balling
all right let's go ahead i think the
tennessee titans you know they got a
running back
all right well listen paul don't do this
just
never listen to a corporation say
they're ashamed they're not ashamed that
just means we got caught
they don't care paul paul there is horse
we stood outside the buccaneer stadium
their [ __ ] prostitute walked up to us
do we know she was a prostitute yes
most of us knew
other people were taking her compliments
thinking that [ __ ] was legit
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh polly positive uh um
she came out of the weeds paul she came
out of the weeds she was like 90 years
past her [ __ ] prime
um
approaching eight guys waiting for an
uber all right uh what do we got here
i'm gonna go
i'm going with the buffalo bills going
into kansas city
hostel
it's loud
they're getting three points
um i'm going to take a chance here
go on honey
chance sorry that the chiefs
i felt like i was shaking diamonds out
of my [ __ ]
bunny bunny hair there whatever the [ __ ]
you call that i'm gonna go with the
buffalo bills plus three
i think that they are a solid football
team
i i i don't know
because i'm thinking i was just the one
we're [ __ ]
no but they've been questioning my homes
which is so [ __ ] stupid they're going
like is she
the same guy
that we saw last [ __ ] year right they
always do that [ __ ] like tom brady goes
to [ __ ] tampa and wins they question
whether bill belichick knows what the
[ __ ] he's doing
as a coach like maybe it was tom brady
maybe tom brady called him as an
eight-year-old when they won as the
giants the first two [ __ ] times um
that's it i'm sticking with it
okay with the buffalo bills paul bam
right down on a [ __ ] coffee table
whatever they do the bill's mafia
paul i'm dancing
with what brought me here going on
buffalo bills going into kansas city
i like it like josh allen here's my
uh
here's my second pick it's also a
favorite
all right i'm getting bo paulie's back
to his old ways
i'm taking the giants no i am taking the
los angeles rams minus two and a half
after a loss in seattle
beating
the seattle seahawks and getting back to
their winning ways after a loss they
only got to win by a [ __ ] field goal
which they're gonna do there you go
first two picks tennessee titans minus
four los angeles rams minus two and a
half over the seattle seahawks i'm gonna
tell you why i like that paul
because seattle i've been betting them
all year they're erratic
okay they're not like the saints
the saints you got no idea who the
[ __ ] gonna show up but there's
something about them paul that is
exactly what they're gonna go into that
loud stadium and they might shut those
people up
um who do i got next paul i have no idea
i'm gonna tell you just for the fun of
it just for the fun
just for the [ __ ] fun of it paul
i'm gonna say it's jacksonville florida
and the [ __ ] and the [ __ ] that you see
walking down the street
is nothing
yes we got a head-to-head baby like that
that [ __ ] we should have to do a
head-to-head every week i think you're
reading the t i think
i'm alex
i don't think they give a
[ __ ] i don't think they give a [ __ ] the
corporation is pretending
to care paul you're talking about this
is the nfl
okay they had they had a they had a
[ __ ]
guy knock a woman out and drag in a
elevator dragging down the hall by her
[ __ ] hair they gave him two games
two games do you think that
they care that he was in a hooters and
some chick
backed her [ __ ] no dad hanging around
ass up into his dick they don't care his
wife cares you can't be a [ __ ]
general and leave your soldiers after
what would happen if generally talking
about
come on what's his face did then world
war ii they called him old blood and
guts his guts and our blood
patton
he did that
general patton walked away after a loss
i don't want to talk [ __ ] about the
wrong general it wasn't eisenhower
who were the biggest generals it was it
was patton eisenhower calvin coolidge i
forget i didn't pay attention i'll tell
you what that urban meyer move staying
with his team flying alone that's a
sneaky pete move that's the sneaky
people all those college coaches all
those college coaches are like [ __ ]
sneaky pete those guys got a little
backdoor exit [ __ ] that guy let's go
head to head tennessee titans that's a
stupid bet i'm throwing away money
because you know what i think the guy's
a bit of a head case
you know they say anytime he has a
[ __ ] pro anytime you know the [ __ ]
wolves are at the door all of a sudden
he goes oh my heart can't take it and he
leaves
he [ __ ] leaves
um
you know what i'm going to take i'm
going to take joe burr
the bengals
getting three
getting three because i think
everybody's taking the packers
i think everybody's liking the packers i
think what the bengals have been doing i
think joe burrows for real i think his
knees feeling great i think people
believe in them
i think cincinnati makes some great ribs
there's a whole bunch of things for me
to like about the cincinnati bengals i
like the paul
i like the bengals their helmets the
same color as my pubes right i'm into it
let's do it all right well
you guys want to lock here's a lock
this is a lock are you ready for this
this is a paul you're like crazy eddie
everything's a [ __ ] insane deal how
can they how can there be two locks in
one week you just talked to that guy who
said a couple times a year
there is a lock
all right
i am going to take
the las vegas raiders
at home after that loss
against
the chicago bears minus five and a half
john gruden's gonna give them a nice
week of practice
let them know look guys we're not
invincible
and then come home and put it on the
bears
i want to ask you this paul you think of
the bears you buying a selling paul you
think they're overrated
i think they got a young quarterback
that's still figuring it out there's a
little bit of quarterback controversy i
don't like still mitch trabitsky who
who's who's quarterbacking out vinnie
bernie come back who's up who's out
there it was it was andy dalton for a
couple weeks and now it's the new kid
from ohio state justin fields jesus
christ dude that that team is like a
halfway house for foster quarterbacks
at some point
if you can't get a ride the nfl if you
just cannot get a [ __ ] contract at
some point you're gonna play quarterback
for the bears and it used to be the
browns
like that was just a revolving it's like
you were walking into macy's
remember that in platoon
hey you're gonna love the nom for
[ __ ] ever right that's the last
quarterback as you come into town and
he's going out of town to be a backup in
in uh denver or some [ __ ] that's so yeah
so that's my third the vegas the vegas
raiders yeah mine is five and i gotta
tell you paul you've picked three games
you've given us two locks
yeah paul versi
two locks blockless paul verzi
all paul's lobster and gamble
um
what am i gonna do here
what am i gonna do here what this is
this is a classic you can tell this
guy's not gonna win money he's just
scrolling looking at games
i don't know why why do the pittsburgh
steelers look good to me minus one
against the denver broncos
is that because craig morton isn't there
anymore paul
maybe no john elway
no peyton manning
you know
dude the regular anything a lot of great
quarterbacks out there but they go oh no
they got they got they got teddy
bridgewater who could present some
problems i i keep thinking teddy is
still out where the hell was he last
year i think teddy got hurt though
yeah that'd be that'd be some
information you probably need to know
before you
yeah teddy's hurt paul i just some
something part of me just wants to take
the cowboys to beat the [ __ ] out of your
giants just i just want to stir the pot
this week i don't know what it is paul
oof
i don't know what it is paul
minus seven at home now that's a [ __ ]
divisional rivalry
i don't like that at all
i see another lock out there this is
lock week i'm calling andrew call this
lock week i see there's another lock out
there you're staring in the face bill
it's staring at you in the face
i can't believe i don't see it paul i
can't believe i don't have your
confidence
what is it about you never playing
football past the high school level that
lets you read these tea leaves so well
ah [ __ ] i i want to have money on that
browns chargers game because i think
it's going to be [ __ ] great ooh
that's a good one that is a good one and
i was really impressed with their
running back last week
i'm wondering about the browns defense
they got they got what's his face is
back the blonde head dude who makes the
one-handed catches he's back on offense
i love baker mayfield i feel like the
guy's the winner but they're playing in
san diego they got the california kid
josh herbert oh god two and a half paul
why is that such a perfect number is it
a letdown game paul they won two they
went back did they beat the chiefs
then they beat the raiders and this is
the week this is the weak paw do they
say that we are the [ __ ]
of the afc
can they say that do they have to
apologize afterwards i'm just stalling
right now can i phone a friend on this
one
um i am gonna take out [ __ ] i'm
taking the cleveland browns i'm going on
four this week paul
i'm taking the cleveland browns low to
low spread that goes either way that's a
good pick
i don't know about that
all right man everything i've said so
far has been stupid
all right well i'm conflicted with my
last one dude because i'm gonna tell you
right now
the steelers at home after a devastating
loss minus one
to the broncos without teddy bridgewater
is really really really appealing
that game is i mean that game andrew you
like that one but then
the other one i love
i literally just threw that out to
andrew didn't even wait for an answer no
you like that one oh he's doing the
thumbs up i didn't see it sorry no he
was doing a thumbs up but then i also
love the monday night ravens minus six
and a half i was looking at that they're
exciting
so do i take the steelers you know
something
there was a i'm gonna [ __ ] flip it i
was gonna take the ravens but you know
what
mike tomlin said all the right things
ben roethlisberger said all the right
things they're at home after a loss and
oh paulie loves the homecoming theory i
mean the homecoming theory has been my
bread and butter
teddy bridgewater if he's is playing
he's banged up i got the steelers minus
one at home after a loss i like the hand
thing
that added some excitement to it i got
the steelers put it on the board
who's that hawk harrelson oh i'm excited
about my picks this week i like them ah
paul i feel like i'm in the clouds right
now
i was looking at that monday night game
the ravens cause you know uncle ray's
maybe gonna show up oh yeah he's gonna
do his dance and split his slacks it's
gonna get everybody all [ __ ] amped up
who the colts got they don't got what's
his face somebody said majikowski
phillip rivers they don't have him
anymore all right
carson wentz
carson came and he went um
oh my god anything better is gonna be 20
minutes tonight
[Laughter]
[Music]
wait a [ __ ] second
kind of oh he's throwing a curveball
he's waiting
i mean how many times can i bet on
arizona and [ __ ] win how many weeks
in a row are they actually gonna [ __ ]
cover is jimmy garoppolo
no he's not practicing this week it
doesn't look like he's playing oh please
he's too good looking to sit out a start
he wants to go down there and have the
cheerleaders winking at him as he goes
down the [ __ ] field
hey jimmy
how did you learn to throw that pigskin
do you wanna [ __ ] me
it's exactly
exactly how it goes
i love you picking the rams in seattle i
love that [ __ ] pick you [ __ ]
bastard
i like your picks paul i think i think
it is a luck all right let's go division
rivalry here the [ __ ] lions in the
vikings
you know i don't like when a division
rival is favored by nine i'm going to
take the [ __ ] lions i'm gonna go all
in 0-4 this week paul i'm betting on the
[ __ ] lions i should have my head
examined
oh [ __ ]
all right
the lions to get off the schneid i like
i like getting getting nine division
all right
well there you have it everybody that's
our week five preview those are our
picks
we are on the we are on the doorstep of
above 500. let's see what happens you're
500 paul because i'm a game behind you
so i'm two games under i'm seven and
nine you're eight and eight
okay
i think you are right i i was one ahead
with the third week so yeah and then we
tied this week
yep before you answer that let me just
get into this
people are like what's going on we are
here
oh sorry no no we are here with uh the
week four preview okay and we got jason
scott it is correct that's my name
yeah we got jason scott with us who is
going to give us the ins and outs
of of bookmaking and what he sees with
the nfl every week and and let us know
if we are just flipping a coin or if
there is some uh method to our madness
so welcome to our anything better nfl uh
week four um you know preview go over
here
perfect so how do we get the numbers can
i tell you it's not the bookmakers it's
the betters
so there are a lot of betters now that
it's incredibly sophisticated there's
one group betting in this country that
employs 300 points
and they're running numbers and they're
doing whatever they are what we have at
ben mgm and the other big operators in
the country too is really sophisticated
data technology and we'll know that well
when bill betts
the market moves he's right so we'll
move it this way towards your market
then another sharp white bet the other
way and we're basically looking for a
balancing point where we can take money
on both sides but as the customer's
telling us
don't let any of the bookmakers take the
credit
we're using that the intelligence is out
there in the market and we land in the
right spot when we're getting money on
both sides well it's the right spot
how do you get well if you have money on
both sides
is it just the how do you make money
then if you've got 50 grand on one side
50 on the other you're paying out is it
just the vig
no no no but i didn't say we take the
same amount of money on both sides we
take the same amount of sharp money on
both sides
we might have a hundred thousand
customers but there's only a hundred
that i that i
that we use to move the market so these
are guys when they bet the market moves
their way let's use stories about our
pros versus joe's
often the public like this week i can
tell you
green bay will be our worst result no
one's going to want to take cincinnati
plus three and a half at home
all the j all the all the joes all the
public will be on rogers but we've
already seen
the sharps are just chipping away at the
bengals already
oh okay
you know we've had a few examples of the
game the other big one was the raiders
versus uh
the ravens in week one all of the pros
wanted to be on the raiders
and so so it evens out so sometimes we
end up with a balanced book but other
times we end up with 90 10. you know
what happens there you guys you guys
actually going like
nervous
when all the pros jump on one
and everybody everybody that listens to
them by pros they're basically not only
betting a lot of money they're driving a
lot of traffic towards what they're
saying
yeah yeah look
this sounds a little bit overconfident
but we've been on four and a half
million markets a year now so we've been
on 350 markets in a football game
we know that our model works that we're
going to have some ups and downs where i
get nervous is the super bowl
because it's just it's so much bigger
than the game and it the liabilities are
out of whack with the rest of the year
but we know in
over a week over a month or every year
we'll sort of hit our big hit our margin
big what's the worst you guys ever lost
well you thought like man we're gonna
have to shut it we have to shut this
casino down
turn it into a smoothie bar
yeah look i think
i think we've had a few this and we're
getting obviously we're getting bigger
each each
month right now we went into arizona
last
uh 9th of september and the numbers
there have been enormous
uh the worst result that i think we
would have had where we sit where the
raven sage is if the chiefs have won
that sunday night football game three
weeks ago
oh yeah
36 35 or whatever it was
that one was as ugly as i've seen
uh jason quick question somebody said
when all the money is going and i mean
obviously nobody knows if this is true
but have you seen this one if all the
money is going somewhere right like
let's just say you know the patriots
like three years ago are going into like
after a lo a hard loss to the dolphins
they're going and it's a lock and
everybody like he said 95 everyone's
going there is it true that that doesn't
that you guys like that because it's
going to go the other way for the most
part or no
no again we pretty much use the same run
if the sharps i think you're talking
about the game
the the patriots and the dolphins in
week 17 a couple of years ago
um and if the sharks are betting one
side like last week
the we couldn't get we couldn't write
the name of the texans so that that line
moved from 16 and a half and it jumped
19 against the bills and you've just got
to wear it when that happens sometimes
it goes our way there's no rhyme or
reason to how many times we win it that
or how many times we lose i think we
mean more than 51 of the time though
when the money rolls that way
and that's it 51 is is is when in this
game it's it's winning and it's really
hard to do is there such thing because
i've texted bill and we're comedians
okay but i've texted bill and i said
this is a [ __ ] lock if i've ever seen
a lock before because i feel and maybe i
could maybe i could be wrong i feel you
get one or two gifts a year
one or two gifts a year where i'm like i
know and but is there such thing as a
lot like in your world not us because
we're just we just gamble but in your
world are you talking to your colleagues
over these things and going oh my god
like this is gonna happen like i feel
good with this one
there's no such thing as a locking sport
there's too many unknowns between
officiating where the players getting
injured i've seen money where it comes
97 3 and you think we have no chance
here it can't possibly help there's no
way we get out of this mess and
sometimes through an act of god it
happens
so no there's your question
[Laughter]
let me ask you this in the 2000s did you
guys know that the nba was fixed
were you literally watching those re you
know
some of those calls just going like
all right there's definitely some
crooked refs
the commissioner is definitely steering
some bigger markets into the finals i
mean
that's like a freaking soap opera yeah
let me let me just say one thing in the
2000s what was happening in the nba was
child's play compared to what was
happening on the atp tour
some of those tennis matches were just
absolutely horrific
really is not trying and you will you'd
be surprised it happens at the biggest
tournaments
if they play dead in round one they
don't want to do it at some small
tournament in cincinnati it happens at
the us open or wimbledon
and there we would see money you'd see
many guys
back from about uh
plus 140 in the start minus a thousand
and they'd win six one six live six two
wow i'm not gonna know what so they got
the other you know what's going on they
like at that point like for tennis
because they got they got the mcenroe
cam
you can't really mess with it too much
so you got to get a player to throw it
huh
i've got a theory that
there was a group that might have been
betting on injuries
where they knew someone was injured and
then they worked out well there's not
much point betting on injuries but let's
manufacture an injury or two
but um i know i know the atp around i
don't know interpol was on it and a few
players it was kept reasonably quiet but
a few players got to line it up
all right but did you know the nba was
fixed because i was sitting there i was
working i was working in australia and
europe then i probably wasn't as close
to when i speak to the guys that have
been here for the last 20 years
i think the answer is no
but now they look back on it knowing
what they know they all say we should
have seen that oh here's i was at a utah
jazz boston celtics game
and i watched these refs in one i don't
know who was refereeing but this game
they were letting them play and i'm like
all right they're letting them play and
then all of a sudden they would just
call in everything
and then again they let them play it was
like there was it was like they they
were like bipolar and just through all
of my years
of watching
just sports in general
like a guy's strike don't zone doesn't
change
a guy like okay if if that's not past
interference like that has to go the
whole game he can't go like wishy-washy
and i've seen that with basketball like
okay no blood no foul or this guy's
calling everything i've never seen a
game where it went no blood no foul to
do whatever the hell you know uh even
look at a guy there's a foul and to go
back again
and i for it just killed me because for
years i was saying it was fixed
and people thought it was full of [ __ ]
and uh then they get the mobbed up ref
who basically says he fixed the
sacramento series and then all like the
only satisfaction i got was everybody
goes well it was just one guy
it was just one guy which i say is
[ __ ] because how long can you be on
an officiating crew before you realize
some guy there is shaving points
yeah look at what came out they waited
for david stern to die before a lot came
out didn't it so you know who knows but
i i think you're right look the other
sport that's notorious worldwide is
qriket and i've spoken to some
professional qriket there's some funny
things happening there as well
filthy
uh
jason how many crickets what about
squash what's going on out there how
many uh
how many people
tried getting their money back from that
bad call that pass interference call uh
the saints rams do you remember that i
do remember that look
some of his online bookmakers we've made
a rod for our
own back with these justice payouts and
bad beat payouts or whatever else we've
created a
cohort of customers that just wins to
mummy every time they don't get their
own way and coming for these great funds
and but it's our fault it's all i was
just gonna say is that what we saw like
how long do you talk to gamblers before
they go it's fixed right it can never be
me because i have all the right picks
it's got to be fixed
someone's injured i need my money back i
said well you could have bet unders on
how many yards he would have still got
to pay him out i can't give you the
money because you've been overs but look
it's it's when you started in this
business were you in the part of book
making where you had to slap some people
around
no no no i i started in races racing so
i started racing
um so i suppose you could say there's
more nefarious stuff there that happens
in all sports globally
well which racing we talk we talking
cars we talking animals
horses
yeah yeah and i know i i've always
worked with the legal crews so i haven't
had the pleasure of having to uh knock
on somebody
what do you think the most degenerate
gamblers
like these people have a problem this
family's crying out in the parking lot
we're talking the dog track is what i
would guess off track betting
right next to the port authority i think
the pandemic in the rise of table tennis
and russian third division ice hockey's
probably a cry out for help
dude i gotta be honest with you
i don't want to out anybody i'm not
gonna say his name i ate a buddy of mine
during the height of the pandemic and
quarantining when there was nothing
going on he was betting like south
korean baseball
he was so jonathan to have actions on
some game and he was staying up at like
three to four o'clock in the morning
you can imagine how i took it when i
wake up at 6 30 one morning we'd done
285 000 on a south korean baseball game
[Laughter]
now who gets blamed for that in your
world
look it's i'm not a people
there is no right or wrong we can we can
only put up prices we can't make you bet
the left side the right side team no but
you work for a corporation so they owe
this somebody always has to take get a
pound of flesh take and it's got to be
the fall guy
you can't tell me they never came to you
going like this this was on you how did
you think this cricket match was going
to go this way i run the show in my team
so yeah they come to me
i must have had a good enough excuse for
that one because i got to last another
week in the room
love dude i love jason he's like a calm
australian tim dillon
it's great uh
so i would think that you'd have to have
your disposition
to survive the stress like how do you
when you stress
when you're just sitting there we're
halfway through the game day and you see
you guys are gonna take a bath
can you just sit there and you're like
joe torre you're just sitting there like
i don't know if you're winning or lose
look if i'm alone
my remote control does take a few
flights around the living room of the tv
thrown on the couch but look publicly
you can't get too happy when you win and
you can't get too sad when you lose or
you're a heart attack victim yeah
i'm lucky i've been doing this long
enough i used to get involved in every
game and yell and scream and cheer now i
just swear on the odd occasion usually
at officials
but um you look you've just got to stay
you've got to stay level or you'd have
to find another career if you've lived
and died by every result how did you get
into this career were you someone that
gambled and after a while you're like
why don't i get on the side that's
winning degenerate so i i grew up in
france my father took me the races when
i was six i was working in banking and
finance
had a midlife crisis at about 28 luckily
my wife had a good job because i said
i'm resigning she said what are you
going to do bet
uh how to go betting professionally was
no good at that so i needed a career and
i was lucky enough to start working
actually with a big betting syndicate
about 2002 in australia who taught me
how to do it properly and i've sort of
learned
you know there's a movie out there with
starring phillip seymour hoffman and the
late great phillip seymour hoffman where
he plays a banker with the gambling
problem owning mahoney is that is that
oh my god i couldn't get through it i
had to watch it in 10-minute increments
it was so like like making my stomach
and knots just watching what this guy
was doing
going just ruining his life but um
anyways let's get on the positive side
of betting winning me and ferzi
okay we're not going to talk about our
first three weeks especially mine we
went three and one
last week i actually had tom brady the
tom brady buccaneers
laying six
and i'm a patriots fan i went against my
own team because i figured if my team
wins i'll be happy if my team loses
i'll win some money and then the worst
case happened my team lost and the other
team didn't cover so
um
i got my kids are too little for me to
be cursing like that i gotta wait till
they're in their teens and then i can
really let the emotions fly but
um
you almost yeah we almost went 4-0 you
you were closer to 4-0 i had one shot at
it with the with the 49ers jason do you
have a super bowl pick do you have a
picks for the super bowl or no yeah look
i'm right now i'm pretty much anything
uh you may not want to hear this as a
tom brady family i'm anything but tom
brady we've we've like we've lost him to
lose a big house in the to win the mvp
and we've lost him to lose a 10-story
block of apartments in the to if they
win the super bowl it's the only name
where writing's tampa they they're a
horrible result for us
okay
here's my thing i actually my pick for
mvp was kyler murray
but i think the nfl still loves a white
quarterback so i want to change it to
josh allen
yeah well what are the odds on that i
just don't think they're going to give
it to a guy like kylo murray what about
matt stafford too
yeah
there's another white guy that's got
safe money
yeah well lamar wanted a couple of years
ago didn't they so they have given it to
one i'm just messing around i got to
keep the comedy going at some point here
you know i'm a cardinals fan so i'm just
hoping
i love kyla murray
dude they got chandler jones and jj
watts on defense i mean
i've been winning money off those guys
they've been covering for me
yeah look we've started well but i mean
a cardinals found i'm not used to
staying positive for too long
the inevitable happened somewhere along
the line
all right what's the over under they're
going to give that stadium a real name
and finally get rid of jobbing.com
i mean how much money i've never even
heard of that website like how do they
have that level of money to keep that
stupid name on the side of that
wonderful stadium
i mean jobbing is something you say when
you get [ __ ] over by the referees why
would you have that on the side
home cooking arena
well i'd love to be able to bet from
that so i i come from australia where
the betting's a lot less regulated so
for instance we'd bet on um
dancing with the stars or the voice or
masterchef
pre-recorded we've been on pre-recorded
television shows and still win
wha what
what did you know once his face did that
he used to bet the afternoon game he bet
the matinee game uh uh
what's this artie lang one of the
funniest chapters in his in his book one
of his many books he talked about how
nobody bet hockey and there was there
was an afternoon game every week and
they started like putting their bets in
for that night's baseball or football
would have football probably football
season
and uh they would bet the afternoon game
and the guy didn't notice and rather
than just using that to fund them they
got greedy
yeah i forget it ended with the guy
saying he was going to kick the [ __ ] out
of him in a mcdonald's on ash wednesday
so he had this big smudge on his face
he said they just sat there laughing at
him
it's one of my many favorite artie lang
stories
that's awesome i remember that that is
awesome all right what's the dumbest
thing
what's the thing the dumbest thing you
ever better the most obscure ridiculous
thing you've ever been on without a
doubt survivor
she got thrown out in the second week
oh
what was what was the uh would you have
to lay out
i think i was on it i was on it about
16 to 1.
i had the right word i had the right
word from a guy in production and i
realized two weeks you know i had the
wrong word
oh no
you had insider information did you go
and talk to that guy you never saw him
again
well he's a good mate of mine actually
but yeah we i haven't taken his tips
since
uh jason can you bet on wheel of fortune
or jeopardy or no
no we haven't got to
look to be honest jeopardy i think it'd
be fantastic the tournament of champions
this is what you got i already have the
line
you have to have the line there's a guy
on the show the over under
if he says uh my smoking hot wife
for some reason everybody on that show
says that
who uh hey joe who do you got here today
well i got my smoking hot wife
and my
son and my daughter well my wife was uh
both times when she was pregnant and
when she was really you know third
trimester or whatever the hell they call
it and she was just hating life i would
just we would watch wheel of fortune in
jeopardy
and uh that was one of the things that
we know one of the you know we watched
it enough
we started breaking down the show people
say my smoking hot wife
you can start there
uh jason a buddy of mine who used to be
a bronx bookie years ago older fella now
he was in he was in the game for many
many years
he said when people come in with the
parlays he said once it gets to three
and four games the percentages they're
just kind of like nah it's just not it's
done you know is that is that would you
say that once you get to three four and
five it's a little much
yeah look it is
without going into it they're our profit
they're our profit margin we did have a
customer the other week that took a 16
leg money line all all 16 legs of the
nfl he got to monday night football and
he had twenty dollars on it about i
can't remember the exact number it was
in the vicinity of 730 000
and he got to the last leg and he had
detroit money line against green bay
he was smart enough to take the 130 000
cash out
but um they'll look down the stories
a lot of good stories like that but
there's
right did he lose the next night
he lost the next night
yeah
he would have lost him yeah we haven't
seen him back since so he's taking the
money
i love that you keep track of them
dude here's my thing my my this is what
i feel like with parlays and all that
like
gambling is like committing a murder
it's like you got to do it by yourself
or you're going to get caught you start
bringing you bring four three four other
teams in
there's just too much that has to go
right
you know what i mean you just i i never
like worst i would ever do remember the
t's the two team t's
i would do that do you guys have those
lightning bets another artie lang story
his normal story a lightning back was
most terrifying huh they're a thing of
the past down the line we've gone the
other way
thousands of prop markets on yards or
you can even bet on how many how many
extra points a kicker will kick
so we've sort of gone we've gone we've
had it i like that one that's a good one
dude how the hell could you ever guess
that
we just i pay a call and about a load of
money and he comes up with a price and
we're trying no i'm not talking you i'm
talking versi versus like oh that's a
good one how the [ __ ] would you know how
many that's one of the most obscure
things ever
how many because i would say three my
bet would be three or four three or four
extra hey paul how many cameramen are
gonna get knocked down when a guy runs
out of bounds
probably one in a game
i would bet one in a game
i take that
i think it happens like every three
games
yeah that's safe money one cameraman
going oh no one person on the sidelines
just
i feel like it ends your career as a
cameraman so they all [ __ ] know
so they got their heads on a swivel but
it still happens because these kids are
so damn fast and you not to mention you
got like that kitchen safe on your
shoulder
dude i was at a game you know that that
thing where they they drive up and down
the um up and down the uh sidelines with
the camera
yeah you know that dude it ran over
somebody
oh geez yeah they backed over this woman
i dude and when i tell you like that
thing was just scrubbed you saw it
nowhere
i couldn't find the story
i was at the uh
rams tampa game
dude the guy driving was just like this
he was just i think i think he drove
over i'm not sure what happened somebody
[ __ ] up though
somebody [ __ ] up paul somebody went
down
lastly last question from me jason
are the i think the new york giants and
i know that i'm a fan
but i think the new york giants season
was on the line last week because we all
know the percentages if a team goes 0-4
i think daniel jones is the real deal
and we got some left in the tank
yes or no
you're three games behind the cowboys
already in the division
i can't see that this year you're going
too far
look i don't disagree with daniel jones
like you know we went for 400 this week
300 the week before he certainly once
he's learned not to turn the football
over he's going to be a hell of a player
i think yeah but i can't say that this
is the year
fair enough
jason if you knew paul the amount of
pain when he just did that little
that little thing
this [ __ ] guy i swear to god they
could be 0-8 and he'd go dude i've seen
eight nate win the playoffs make the
playoffs like this guy well you know you
know what though jason gave me a little
he gave me a little pat he said look
daniel jones is the guy you know just i
think things could go good
you know we know we all know what saquon
barkley is if the offensive line is good
i'll take that you know we are three
games back to the cowboys cowboys look
great dak looks great but i'll take that
nice step in the right
direction i appreciate you jason thank
you sir
i appreciate you i hope everybody uh a
lot of money i hang out with him he's
one of the most positive people i've
ever met he's i need that i need to just
see somebody just
be dealt at hand and still have a smile
on his face like he's getting a
continental breakfast well others say
that i'm delusionally positive but hey
it is what it is
all right my question would be who's
your top dog in the afc
now that tom brady is two years removed
ben roethlisberger is up there the bills
have been just making they've been
kicking the [ __ ] out of everybody do
they have an impressive win though
you can only beat what's in front of you
you know you have to say week one was
the
the exception
uh and they played kansas to play the
chiefs this week don't they in in uh
arrow in february so this is this is
their chance to make a statement they
look the best team to me right now then
the chiefs have lost two in a row yeah
remember how tampa looked about week
four last year
bloody terrible so controlled very
quickly
and then what happened was their player
coach yelled at the offensive line
mid-october especially that red-headed
guy making us gingers look bad he got in
his freckled ass
and then that was it that was the
turning point i won't even say that
might have been even been closer to
november
but i didn't have an injury either that
were blessed with luck on
i'm a little dubious about them this
year and now you said money money on
brady getting back this year is is is
not good or good yeah no 10 9 10 11
we we have the customers coming every
week we've had more money on him we've
heard double on him than we've had on
any other player even preseason we
couldn't we couldn't write a bet for my
homes it was all for brady so
they love him
really as it should be i mean the guy's
been to 10 super bowls and won seven of
them i mean that's that's like cartoon
numbers that's movie numbers paul
doesn't happen
um
all right well listen uh
i'd love to have you on again because i
think what you do for a living
is so fascinating and i would also like
to tap in next time we have more time
talk more about the insane things that
you can gamble on
in australia because i've been there
like three or four times just to do
shows had i known this whole extra level
of fun
i didn't i mean if i if i could gamble
on american idol i would actually watch
it
exactly
i had to be a bookmaker i wasn't smart
enough to be a comedian and these hands
are not good for digging ditches so
um
i'd love to come back
yeah you know we got hotel sweet hands
definitely
we gotta have you no we gotta have you
back man it's it's because it's so funny
because you're just like this calm voice
of reason and we're just this is perfect
i love it man thanks
if you got the time maybe you could
check in you know every month or so as
we're we're sitting here gambling seeing
how we're doing because uh we could also
have some listeners ask some questions
because
you know
most of us gamble but you know we're all
fascinated by the sam rothstein's
yes
and that whole side of the business is
amazing so thank you so much for coming
on too thank you okay cool
all right jason thank you buddy i
appreciate it
guys as you know anything better has
paired with bet mgm
okay go to bed go to bed mgm
all right we'll be using the bet mgm
lines all year
okay for the picks and uh we'll have
special offers for our listeners each
week if you haven't signed up at bet mgm
use bonus code burr burr you'll get a
hundred dollars free after placing your
first one dollar bet here's how it works
you download the bet mgm app you sign up
and you put in bonus code burr b-u-r-r
place your first dollar money line bet
on any game you'll receive a hundred
dollars in free bets immediately after
placing your bet regardless of the
outcome of your bet just make sure you
use bonus code bur when you sign up hey
guys visit bet mgm.com for terms of
conditions 21 years of age or older to
wager arizona colorado dc iowa
indianapolis michigan new jersey
pennsylvania tennessee virginia west
virginia or wyoming only excludes
michigan disassociated persons please
gamble responsibly guys gambling problem
call 1-800 next step arizona 1-800-522
colorado dc nevada wyoming and virginia
1-800-270-7117
for a confidential help michigan 1-800
gambler new jersey pennsylvania west
virginia 1-800 bets off iowa call or
text the tennessee red line eight
hundred eight eight nine nine seven
eight nine tennessee or call one eight
hundred nine with it in indiana guys
there you go that responsibility all
right that's it i hope you enjoyed the
bet mgm talk and uh now we're gonna do a
little musical interlude the music
picked out by the always lovely the
always wonderful the incredibly
musically talented a bunch of different
other talents this man has andrew
themless and after that we'll have a
bonus half hour of a thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast from a few years ago or however
the hell he works it out that's it have
a great weekend you [ __ ] and i'll talk
to you
on monday
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday october 7th
2013 october
we're all the way into the fall here it
is officially
october it's the month of pink
yes it is
are you aware that cancer is in
somebody's boobs
hey
i actually think that they weren't
wearing um the the the the pink stuff as
much
i didn't think there was or maybe i'm
just used to it
is that what it is
i have no idea
i got no [ __ ] idea all i know is i
watched some football yesterday
and uh
first of all
who's kidding who who is kitten who i'll
tell you who's kidding who i'm kidding
myself
when i say this next thing let's go red
sox
here we go
team that i haven't watched all [ __ ]
year boom boom i've watched two red sox
games this whole year
game one in game two of the playoffs
hey
like what's his face says in the
warriors i've been busy
all right i was too [ __ ] busy to
watch him
that that isn't the truth
the truth of the matter is uh one of my
favorite players tested positive for
some substance in 2010 and at that point
i was like you know what i'm gonna give
baseball a [ __ ] rest here okay
i'm sick of feeling like a [ __ ]
eight-year-old not even an
eight-year-old a four-year-old
who's who's you know and then they won
the championship and they lived happily
ever after and i go to bed with my
little broken smile because my young two
faces are starting to fall out i get a
quarter under my pillow and i believe
that everybody did it in an honest
[ __ ] way and then three four years
later
espn comes out
with yet another guy
another fresh-faced white dude you know
with a little haberdash on or maybe a
former player
maybe a former player comes on and then
they they [ __ ] let me know that
everything that i thought was wasn't
everything that i thought is isn't
and uh that i'm just a dumb freckled
[ __ ]
and i just i got i got sick of it so
so i haven't been watching i mean i i
kind of you know was watching as they
dismantled terry left town
theo epstein easy's over out there in
chicago
and i watched the gradual the whole
thing disintegrate but um
i do you know what's funny
i was actually texting another buddy of
mine like oh hey you've been watching
the red sox at all and he goes yeah yeah
i've been watching him and i opened
openly admitted i was like dude i'm
beyond [ __ ] bandwagon this year and
he laughed and he goes so am i yeah we
both live out [ __ ] on the west coast
now
and we're watching the game
and he was literally saying like
he was thinking [ __ ] like hey you know
that asian guy we got is really good
neither one of us knew his name our
relief pitcher who i i can't even say
his lights out because i've watched 18
innings
um
some of it with the sound down and i
don't even know the name of our closer
i just know that he's asian and he's
been killing it
so um
oh my god you're gonna see it if the red
sox win the world series and i go out
and get the hat because you know you got
to go out and get the hat right
put your arms around other fans and
we'll all
go down together and you act like you've
been there
well i'm here to admit
right you know what i'm doing right now
i'm doing that thing when somebody [ __ ]
up in a game
and afterwards when the reporters come
to the locker room
rather than let the reporters say how
bad you sucked you just own up to it
you know i didn't i didn't get it done
today you know
but uh i take full responsibility i
uh i let my teammates down
i let down my mom
my high school coaches
you know if everybody hates me i'm gonna
let you know i hate myself even more
than you hate me okay
i suck look at me i'm pointing right in
my face i suck okay
so you don't need to write it
that's what i'm doing
before you guys call me out
for being old billy bandwagon i'll i'm
letting you know i am all right bruins
i'm on board from day one although i
haven't watched the second of it yet but
i taped the [ __ ] games over there
um i was on the road
all right i've been busy
but [ __ ] busy
i went this week i went el paso to san
jose
then i went up to seattle
um
and then i went down to uh phoenix
arizona another great [ __ ] week but
if it was airport airport airport
airport
airport is that what it was no i drove
to el paso
that was a good time you know the old me
would have gone
in a straight shot 12 hours i got this
i'll leave it 10 in the [ __ ] morning
get there at 10 at night have myself a
[ __ ] quesadilla
and i would just go into bed but uh
i'm [ __ ] old now
i got right around tucson and i was like
i'm tired
ah my ass hurts and um
i got a
[ __ ] hotel and i gotta tell you it
was great
it was great i drove for like eight
hours
that's what i did i drove for eight
and uh and then the next day i woke up
and i drove
basically from tucson to el paso and it
was [ __ ] it was awesome man
going through the badlands of uh
new mexico
but there's just [ __ ] nothing out
there you know what's funny somebody
sent me on twitter was saying you know i
hope bill doesn't have a beautiful drive
out to el paso so i don't have to hear
about it and that [ __ ] made me laugh
so goddamn hard just because of what is
behind that like how miserable was your
[ __ ] childhood that you don't want to
hear somebody say that they had a great
time and that this is a beautiful
country
like you'd much rather
have me go out there and be like there's
[ __ ] nothing out there you know a
bunch of [ __ ]
[ __ ] you indian reservations you know
we should just kill the rest of them
right and put up a [ __ ] sports bar
you know
[ __ ] [ __ ]
that's but you know what but he's
younger
i think he was younger judging by his
avatar
huh you like that i picked up that
little word of technology
avatar see i
a [ __ ] week ago i just thought it was
a movie
where [ __ ] floated around you
and there was these blue people was like
it was smurf porn right if you stray
like it was smurf porn
that's what that [ __ ] movie was smart
porn combined with the way that guy drew
those pictures on good times when they
pretended jimmy walker painted him
remember that they'd have a dude dunking
a basketball and his arm would be like
extra long that's combined
both of those schools
i feel
you know and at the end of the day
i don't remember a [ __ ] second of
that movie
i just remembered somebody had uh
i just remember the the
didn't everybody have like hair like
every cornerback in the nfl
except it was blue
i don't know i don't [ __ ] know
they had the same body types of that
dude who goes right from high school
into the nba
you know
not quite a boy not quite a man body and
you're [ __ ] six ten
am i thinking of the right [ __ ] who
anyways
judging by these kids avatar
he was uh he was you know young he was
in his 20s so
your 20s
is all about taking your childhood out
on everyone that you run into
you're not you don't realize that you're
doing it
at least this is how my life went now
granted if you had if you had a
wonderful childhood
if there was no conflict i mean what is
a wonderful childhood what
um
whatever if you had one where people um
there's no way that there's no way to
not [ __ ] up your kid
what it really is is you're trying to
[ __ ] it up
the least the least amount that you can
you're trying to send your kid out into
the world with the least amount of
[ __ ] issues
so
i don't know i guess that they they
could be happy
and then also that you don't have to be
sitting in the back of a courtroom in
complete denial
that yeah you know your kid [ __ ] a dog
[Laughter]
no i just think it's going gonna come
we'll think yeah present the evidence i
think you know
yes there was dog hair in his pubes but
that doesn't mean anything no it doesn't
it's circumstantial
um
maybe that's what it is so whatever so i
didn't get upset by that guy i mean my
how my life went was in my 20s
my early 20s i was like this [ __ ]
like
really quiet
got along with everybody and then all of
a sudden out of nowhere like my anger
would flare up like that fake volcano in
front of that [ __ ] casino out there
in the desert
where is it treasure island
right
um and then people would be like what
the [ __ ] is that as they look for their
eyebrows
and uh then i didn't know how to
apologize that would be the end of the
relationship
and
late 20s sort of came to the surface 30s
brutal
came out of the 30s right before i hit
the ground i started to pull it up a
little bit now i'm somewhere in the
middle i'm a [ __ ] mess everybody
i really am i don't know why you're
listening to this other than maybe it
makes you feel better about yourself i
don't [ __ ] know or maybe you just
hate your job do you guys watch any
football yesterday
great games some great games and some
not so great games i'll tell you if you
guys taped the patriots bengals game if
you were a fan of ugly
ugly
ugly turn away from the tv football that
was an ugly one
and um
i don't know
i don't know this is gonna be uh i have
to watch the rest of the game because i
was so [ __ ] exhausted i only got two
hours sleep so i watched i watched right
up until the third quarter when it went
off the rails so i still have to watch
the rest of the game when it starts
raining and all that type of [ __ ] but uh
it was just neither team could score a
[ __ ]
point
a bunch of goddamn field goals
um and the patriots lost but i whatever
what are you gonna do
i mean i thought at this point we'd be
[ __ ] two and three
four and one i'll take it
but uh
i don't know i don't know what to think
about anybody at this point you're
looking at the the goddamn
cowboys broncos game and all you [ __ ]
big buckled big stupid hat [ __ ]
facelift
botoxed overly made up [ __ ] in dallas
if you [ __ ] jump on
tony romo after that game you are you're
a [ __ ] [ __ ]
how many points does the guy have to
score
to win a goddamn game [ __ ] put up 48
points
against the broncos
48 [ __ ] points and then again he
throws an interception good same old
tony
that's the same old tony right there i
swear to god he's like a ranch hand i
used to have he could brand [ __ ] he'd
burn 800 cattle in the [ __ ] row and
then he'd drop it on his foot wouldn't
get that last one
i mean you don't get that last one or
what the [ __ ] you do the whole herd for
you ain't gonna do the whole [ __ ]
hurt i'll [ __ ] do it myself there
that [ __ ]
maybe not with that [ __ ]
accent
but listen man the guy scored 48 [ __ ]
points in his goddamn defense put him in
a situation where now he had to go out
and score better than 51 just to get a
goddamn victory so yeah you got to sling
it
and that dude who picked it up was laid
out it was an incredible interception
all right so
hey i'm [ __ ] sticking with tony over
here
um and then you got the broncos
who uh they're doing that miami dolphin
dan marino thing right now with this
they're just outscoring people they're
letting up a lot of [ __ ] points
they're letting up a lot of points and
i'll tell you as a fan of nfl football
when i have seen in the past
is um
if you score a zillion points during the
regular season and you let up half a
zillion points
uh you lose in the playoffs playoffs
because you end up running into [ __ ]
amazing defenses that win games 20 to
17. when you run into that [ __ ] team
all right and they slow the whole
[ __ ] thing down
you know slow down the other offense and
that type of [ __ ] then you're done if
they have any sort of running game and
then they keep your [ __ ] guy off the
field all of a sudden you're sitting
there with your pockets turned inside
out going where's my uh proverbial
football wallet there
jesus bill
she's got diarrhea porn out of your
mouth this week don't you talking all
kinds of [ __ ] yeah so i don't even know
i don't i don't even know where the
broncos i don't know who's shot i don't
know who's not
um
then you have seattle
we are the loudest right they [ __ ] go
in
and um
they got beat by the goddamn cults
and last week
if [ __ ] uh that dude from the texans
who according to paul verzie i was
talking this morning he's throwing a
pick six four weeks in a row if he
doesn't throw a pick six
that's two games they lost on the road
and that's a knock against that team
they're saying that they're not good on
the road jesus christ this is shaping up
to be a very interesting football season
and you know why that is because they
have a hard cap
so everybody's in it
you hear that baseball
nba basketball
i haven't even watched baseball i don't
even know if it's working or not
um
anyway so there you go so there's my
sports talk for the week
hey ladies
anybody out there left
any ladies left i went on the road this
week with uh
joe bartnick
rose boat tailgate legend
the godfather of our [ __ ] tailgate if
anybody's getting his ring kissed on
that wonderful [ __ ] new year's day
it's joey b i gotta tell you something
that [ __ ] guy
made me laugh
i i just that guy kills me if you get a
chance to see joe bartnick
do stand up um
i don't know how to describe it it's
just watching a crowd
figure out who the [ __ ] he is it takes
them i swear it takes them about two and
a half three minutes and then they're on
board and they're
going on the ride
and uh
i don't i don't know how to tell you
what the [ __ ] he was he he went we were
walking through seattle and he started
talking about homeless people
he had me [ __ ] die and laugh and i'm
like you got to do that tonight and he
tried it out when we were at the uh
the beautiful
pageant theater
in uh in seattle
and by the way we were both walking
around talking about how much we love
that [ __ ] city man that is an uh
underrated
seattle washington especially if it's if
it's sunny up
sunny
thank you for the [ __ ] you took last
night um
the [ __ ] am i talking about you know
what's crazy about seattle every time i
fly in first of all usually it's raining
and i'm freaking out that we're gonna
crash but this time
it was sunny
and uh
we were flying out over whatever the
puget sound whatever the hell it is and
i had the window seat and i looked down
and
you know i've been meaning to find this
[ __ ] house
you ever go and you land you're coming
in for a landing and you're looking down
over these neighborhoods and it just
looks like you know
you know the little houses all made out
of ticky tack that [ __ ] and then
every once in a while you fly over one
of those
illuminati neighborhoods
and it could even be your home state and
you it just so because the winds are
different they just flew over a
different area that day and you look
down like you're going what where the
[ __ ] are those houses
is that a school
or is that a house what is that
and
it was one of those deals we were coming
in i feel like a different way
than usual and i had the window seat and
i looked out
and what i saw
it can't be described as a mansion
whatever what's the next size up from a
mansion
like a villa
is that the word you use you know what
it looked like you guys ever seen that
movie the dirty dozen with lee marvin
and charles bronson
do you remember when all those nazi
officers were in that that
they were in france and they weren't
that they you know because they were
occupying france and they took over the
whole [ __ ] uh
country and so they were in that giant
looking like castle type thing that all
these rooms and these that's what this
thing looked like
and um
we're flying over the thing and it was
surrounded by these beautiful tall trees
all around the house and then on three
sides of it it looked like
three
manicured
fairways
in the shape of like football fields
absolutely [ __ ] immaculate
and it was right on this like peninsula
and there was water around it and then
you had to walk like a hundred yard
you'd walk like [ __ ] look it looked
like
200 feet of woods from the house and
then a hundred yard football field
and then right on the edge of the water
was one of the coolest looking
in-ground pools i've ever seen in my
life like you'd have to take a [ __ ]
tram
from the house to get to the pool
and uh
i don't know i'm gonna try and find it
i don't know how to tweet it or
something like that i don't wanna tweet
somebody's [ __ ] house but
uh i don't know who lives there but
if there is people that meet every day
to decide whether it rains or not
that guy who lives there or that lady
they are at that meeting casting their
vote because i i don't know i've never
seen a [ __ ] house like that in my
life
um
so anyway so we go into seattle
and as usual and this is the last time
i'm doing it i went down to that stupid
[ __ ]
fisherman's wharf there where they throw
them throwing
the fish
and as i was walking there this is the
first time i walked in i was like why am
i going down here this is such a
touristy thing to do you know the food's
gonna suck and it's gonna be overpriced
and that's exactly what the [ __ ]
happened
you know i i got like some crab burger
bartnik got his his burger his burger
was cold
mine was all right
and i'm like of course nobody from
seattle goes down here to see a bunch of
[ __ ] taurus buying seattle magnets
and sweatshirts
where the [ __ ] did they go and i forgot
to ask
i don't know so anyway so i had a [ __ ]
sandwich
with a side of fries there
so uh then i went out i did the show at
the paramount theater
and um
it was crazy like the theater was one of
these deals where like you um
i don't know just the way it was set up
like you said the joke and there was
like half a second pause and then then
you'd hear the laughter coming back to
the stage so kind of [ __ ] up my timing
at first and everything went great
and
in the end somebody finally yelled
seattle and i kind of brought up the
fact that i'd sung we are the loudest or
whatever i got booed a little bit but
they they were cool about it
and um
i don't know it was just it was an
awesome show and then i found out that
uh dave chappelle was in town right
around the corner so me and bartnik like
two little school girls
literally ran over to where he was
performing and got to watch the last 10
minutes of his set which of course
his last 10 minutes crushed anything
that i've ever written in my entire
career
[Laughter]
you know it was a nice uh
it wasn't that what do you call it uh
not eye opener whatever just you know
the second you're thinking like hey i
think i'm getting a handle with this oh
wait a minute i still suck okay cool
um so it was an awesome night and then
we went to this [ __ ] bar
chappelle was over at the moore theater
which is the one where eddie veda
and pearl jam made that one where he was
in the dirty shorts
right and he dropped down into the crowd
after he stared at him for an
uncomfortably long time
um
so we went to this bar right around the
corner
and it just seemed shady the second we
walked in and
according to bartnik the bouncer said it
when we walked in after he checked
bartnik's id he said good luck
so
i proceed to drink way more than i
should have
and you know the end of the night comes
and i'm hungry so i go up to the front
desk and i'm like yeah you guys are
rosario's they're like no they're
[ __ ] drunk leprechaun here's a pizza
menu get away from the front desk you're
scaring the ladies
so i vaguely remember this i went
upstairs
and i'm trying to order a pizza and
something in my back of my head goes you
shouldn't be eating like this is this
hour so i call them up and they were
like uh thank you for calling gina's
pizza can you hold please and you know
can you hold please they don't wait for
a response they immediately put you on
hold they so they should just say hey
welcome to [ __ ] freddy's pizza i'm
putting you on hold but they don't
welcome to tony's pizza can you hold
please and they put me on hold so i'm
sitting there and i'm sitting there and
i think i actually passed out for a
second and i woke up and i was still on
hold
or i think i passed out with my eyes
open like one of those things i just
started thinking about [ __ ] and i forgot
what i was doing and i was just like why
is one of my ears hotter than the other
oh i'm on hold
and i was like ah [ __ ] it let me call
back so i called back again hey welcome
to gino's pizza can you hold please put
me on [ __ ] hold again and as i was
like no no i just wanna be and they
already had me on hold
so i sat there for another [ __ ]
couple minutes my ears getting hot again
so i hang up
and i don't really remember what i said
but i called them back
and as they're going hey welcome to
tony's pizza i just start dropping
f-bombs
go you know [ __ ] put [ __ ]
something on [ __ ] hold your [ __ ]
house so i just want to own a [ __ ]
bee [ __ ] i can't remember i said [ __ ]
like 58 times and the guy in the other
end goes hey buddy buddy you need to
relax and i just kept i was like it was
like i was filibustering with tourette's
i and i plowed right through that
[ __ ] [ __ ]
he just hung up on me and then went over
the bed
probably passed out face down
you know in the pillow breathing in
carbon dioxide for the rest of the night
and woke up with a brutal
brutal hangover
as i had to fly to phoenix the next day
and i had one of those ridiculously
smiling like a [ __ ] maniac
uh stewardesses
like i don't know what happened like
she's still putting on all this makeup
to the point she looked like some crazy
clown
and she was just like hey how are you
today
yeah
you know like adding
syllables
to [ __ ] one-syllable words day yeah
and it was just kind of like
can i get you a drink this morning
[Music]
just [ __ ] like
you can see it her life
was
almost over the hill of hope
and she was just gonna go she's just
pulling back the throttle and she's
gonna go as positive as she possibly can
hoping if she puts this [ __ ] energy
out there something loving is gonna come
back to her
it was one of the most uncomfortable
[ __ ] flights i've ever had and i was
hungover
and the more i was coming at her with my
negative energy like can you [ __ ]
stop smiling at me
all right
i just need some water
right to get rid of the throbbing in my
head it made her pull back on the stick
even more to the point i think she went
into a stall
um
i don't know
it was one of those deals it probably
i'm sure she was completely normal and
it was just the fact that i was so
goddamn drunk
that uh or so hung over
that um
that her extra bubbly
personality was coming across that way i
don't know as always
as always i was probably in the wrong
but i'm too immature to admit it
so with that that's the beginning of the
podcast by the way you are listening to
the monday morning podcast if you just
happen to walk by somebody's ear buds
um i do one of these every single week
and if you're probably sitting there
going hey how do i support this podcast
how can i have
help out
this freckled [ __ ] how can i do it
this real [ __ ]
how can i not say [ __ ] him and
everything that he does
uh well this is what you can do you can
go to the podcast page you can click on
the uh
part yeah you go to billboard.com you
click on the podcast page and over on
the right there's a banner for
amazon.com and if you are thinking of
buying anything if you just go to amazon
through my site
you click on it you go to amazon
everything still costs the same
and i get credit for driving traffic to
their site they give me a little skim
off the top i take the skin put it in my
pocket take a little bit of skim out
give it to the wounded warriors project
so you're helping me and you're helping
the troops
and you're helping america
um
or you can always also download one of
my specials if you'd like or buy the
hard copy
dvd version of it off of the merch page
that's a wonderful thing to do so it
makes a great gift
makes a great gift christmas coming up
for someone you really don't give a [ __ ]
about you just want to spend 20 bucks
there you go you [ __ ]
um laugh it up [ __ ] i'll see you next
christmas
all right and it makes a great gift i
think at this point
uh for a hipster
because i know that they've moved on to
cassette tapes
they're somewhere in like cassette tapes
right now so eventually dvds are gonna
be cool again because it's not a blu-ray
and um you can sell it to them
in a couple of years and then they can
go off on their [ __ ]
bicycle that's ten feet in the [ __ ]
air for no no apparent reason all right
uh dollar [ __ ] slave dollar shave club
everybody
this is blowing up everybody's loving
this even the ladies i think they're
loving it when they shave their legs and
their private parts their dollar shave
club there are so many things in the
world that irritate me
things like you get your motorcycle
license and everybody goes it's not a
matter if it's a matter of when but if
you buy a scooter nobody says that to
you they just call you a [ __ ]
you know or if you ride down the street
on a bicycle
like that is even more dangerous
than a motorcycle riding out in traffic
listening to reo speedwagon so you can't
even hear the traffic around you
anyways there's a lot of things that
irritate me overly positive stewardesses
when i have a hangover when there are so
many things that can irritate you why
would you want to add razors to the list
that doesn't make any sense what are you
saying bill i'm telling you through
dollar shave club it's time to stop
milking your razor blade i know with
brand name razors that you're used to
paying outrageous prices and exhausting
those razors until they start to look
like a rusty soda can well guess what
it's time to move on dollar shave club
delivers amazing quality blades to your
door for just a few bucks a month
they're cheap and they're sending them
right to you
you can be in your damn underwear
walk up to the door freak out the f the
fedex guy whoever the hell they send
them and you got a nice smooth shave
within 10 minutes of that depending on
your abilities
for opening packages anyways let me let
me carry on here never think about it
again they send you a pack every month
so you can change your blades every week
i love these guys and your face is going
to love them too they got a new one they
have a new product called a one wipe
charlie
it's a butt white for men and it's
classy
check out the video for that and sign up
for your razors today go to
dollarshaveclub.com forward slash burr
that's
or go to billboard.com and click on the
dollar shave club banner
all right hulu plus everyone
you've probably tried hulu.com if you're
even remotely informed if you're in the
loop if you're one of the cool kids
you've probably tried hulu.com well
guess what now it's time to try hulu
plus you can watch your favorite shows
anytime anywhere hulu plus plus lets you
watch thousands of hit tv shows and a
selection of acclaimed movies on your
television or on the go with your
smartphone or tablet and it all streams
in hd for the best viewing experience
possible with hulu plus you can watch
your favorite current tv shows like
saturday night live community family guy
or maybe breaking bad
you can also check out exclusive content
including hulu originals like the
awesomes starring snl seth myers and
moonboy starring chris o'dowd from
bridesmaids hulu plus offers a great
selection of acclaimed films for only
7.99 7.99 a month you can stream as many
tv shows and movies as you want wherever
you want right now you can go you can
try hulu plus for two weeks when you go
to huluplus.com
that's a special offer offer for my
listeners
make sure you use huluplus.com bill so
you get the extended free trial all
right that's very important if you want
the extended free trial hulaplus.com
slash bill all right hula com hulu.com
huluplus.com bill come on bill
do that now or click hulu plus banner on
the podcast page at billboard.com and
lastly e-voice everyone
e-voice
all right you have an idea for a
business you want to get out from
underneath the crushing weight of your
cubicle
if you're an entrepreneur and a customer
calls do you want to seem like you're in
a high-rise window window view fancy
pants office or do you want them to know
that you're sitting there in your
underwears
with e-voice you can create the
appearance of entire building sales
customer support tech support you name
it people are going to think you got it
why because of e-voice give your
customers the royal treatment with
e-voice e-voice will fall we're forward
business calls to your home mobile
device or any other number you choose
wherever you are e-voice will find you
if you don't have time to take your call
take a call it's not a problem it will
be routed to you as a voicemail and you
can read it at your convenience as an
email however you want it they can send
it to you e-voice not only gives you an
edge over your competitors it takes away
the edge the big companies have over you
right now and that's the biggest selling
point right there okay and now you can
try evoice for free for 30 days go to
evoice.com or just go to the podcast
page at billboard.com and click on the
e-voice banner all right back to the
podcast you know i mentioned in that
i mentioned that whole thing about
motorcycles scooters
and bicycles now i look i know
motorcycles are dangerous
but uh how come a scooter is not
dangerous
what because it's it's some little
skinny nerd riding the [ __ ] thing or
a celebrity chef or some lady with a
little ladybug helmet on
all of a sudden get t-boned by a [ __ ]
f-100 isn't a problem
i saw a guy today was on on a was riding
a bicycle in los angeles on a major
[ __ ] street
all right
and he had his earbuds in listening to
music and he's doing that thing where
he's riding like eight to ten feet off
of the curb and this traffic behind him
having to slow down and go around him
it's
that to me is is
more suicidal than riding a motorcycle
in la without a helmet i might be wrong
but i'm just saying
i know bill you're just saying hey by
the way we have some we have some
[ __ ] hilarious
uh
youtube videos that uh some listeners
made about this podcast
um two fans made a youtube video
um
two different fans okay one fan made one
it's a collection of every oh
jesus that i said in the past year
uh it's amazing
and right as it gets annoying he always
has it become funny again it probably
it's probably going to annoy you guys
but it's like the amount of work that it
took to put the whole thing together
um
it's [ __ ] it might be something you
want to get a little high and then
listen to
um or drunk or whatever and then call a
pizza parlor and curse you your brains
out at him um we'll have the link for
that one and the other
is text art
of basically um text and art added to me
singing a song when i sang that song do
you know what it means to miss new
orleans
they did this really cool thing that
that once again
made me laugh out loud and i don't i
don't laugh about a lot of things
you know why because i'm a sad
clown um
so by the way i didn't
the el paso gig finally happened
it finally happened i want to thank
everybody who came out to that everybody
came out to san jose that was another
great
oh [ __ ] i forgot that story
we we performed there just a f awesome
crowd
and at the end of the night we we stayed
in a hotel where we we just had to walk
a block and a half over to the venue so
me and bartnik are leaving right we had
a couple of crowns when we were in uh
the theater there and we're walking out
and um
we should have went right we went left
we zigged and we should have zagged
and would we just start walking and
we're just kind of feeling good because
it was a great show and we were going to
meet a couple of friends to go have
something to eat
and uh we're walking and we're walking
and we're walking we're walking
and all of a sudden we went like 10
blocks and barnett's findings like dude
where the [ __ ] is the hotel and i'm like
i don't know
and it's starting to rain and i got my
[ __ ] box of dvds we're walking down
the street looking like we both just got
kicked out by our [ __ ] wives you know
and uh
i don't know like
i just finally googled where the hell
our hotel was
on the smartphone and i realized we were
like 15 blocks in the other direction we
were late the people who wanted to meet
us for dinner were texting us long story
short next thing you know i'm on one of
those uh
we took a bicycle taxi
right we took a bicycle
taxi
me and bartnik sitting there with a
glass of crown royal each in a plastic
cup
i got my i had my suitcase my wheelie
suitcase with my dvds in it he has his
cds and we're sitting there riding this
guy with a green mohawk is riding us in
this light misting rain and we're
drinking
whiskey and it was [ __ ]
it was hilarious great
the wind in our hair or what's left of
mine
and uh we're just sitting there laughing
our ass off
we couldn't look at each other in the
back of this [ __ ] bicycle rickshaw
without cracking up because it's kind of
a romantic thing to do
and i don't know it was just one of
those things just laughing our ass off
then we went to this um
this pizza on a pizza this italian
restaurant
a famous one where they have like career
waiters so the waiters are unbelievable
and they got like wear the jackets and
stuff and i know i've eaten there before
i want to say it was called joe's
and i got a chicken palm that was
delicious that was [ __ ] delicious so
did i forget any other stories oh and
then the last night we worked at the
celebrity celebrity theater in phoenix
arizona it was in the round
and those are always just immediately
amazing um
shows and i i got to send the videos
that i took there just the amount of
people that have performed there george
carlin taped a special there his second
one ever
in 78 louis ck just did one there
um paul mooney had worked there all
these amazing comics and then all these
bands
stevie ray vaughan and the instep tour
miles davis
liberace performed there the first time
they could make
the thing just the stage turn a little
bit
um cream played there
van halen on their first tour played
there was [ __ ] insane
tony bennett all of these unbelievable
names
and then uh two jackasses
from the rose bowl tailgate so it was
amazing to become part of that history
and then afterwards they have this whole
lounge area where the entire staff hangs
out and drinks and uh we were sitting
there back in the green room
and i was like i said you know i had
some friends that came to visit
a buddy of mine from back in the day and
he married this woman from new
zealand and uh
they they came up she had a 16 year old
daughter from a previous relationship a
marriage or whatever and they came up to
us and they said you know we have a
tradition in new zealand that if a
performer comes to town and gives a
great show
that we give him a performance back and
then her 16 year old daughter came up
and started doing this thing on the
table i guess some people have ripped it
off on youtube but i guess this is the
original one
where they start she just started
with this cup
and then as she's it's really was
syncopated and all this [ __ ] just to
keep that going and then she started
singing this song about thank you for
coming to town and we're sorry that
you're leaving and when she would get to
the chorus of it her mother from across
the room started singing the other
harmony
it was one of the most pure artistic
things i've ever seen it was a paper cup
and two people singing
and for half this i was going to start
filming it with my iphone and i was like
no that's what's wrong with [ __ ]
everything right now why can't this
moment just happen
and i can't just sit here and watch it
rather than viewing it now
through my phone screen you know what i
mean so um
so that happened and then the last
second we were i was like you know hey
they said that you know the staff's
upstairs drinking
and they brought us through the
catacombs of the place and all of a
sudden you walk into like this sinatra
like [ __ ] lounge and they're all
drinking we all come walking in they're
like hey next thing you know
i'm getting shit-faced again so needless
to say i'm back to drinking juice feast
of famine right now so i'm juicing all
day today i'm even gonna do yoga like a
[ __ ] twinkle toe over there
and um
i'm gonna i'm gonna get my [ __ ] self
i'm gonna get knock off the booze weight
from this weekend
so anyways
jesus christ have i run my mouth enough
um
oh by the way is anybody uh
anybody
else kind of looking at it's
like when the government was going to
shut down i don't know about you guys
but i was terrified like is there going
to be anarchy is going to be people
storming my [ __ ] house with torches
like
people hung from uh
you know street lights and that type of
[ __ ]
uh it's amazing how part of the
government shut down and like unless you
work for them you don't really notice
[Laughter]
why do we need governments
um
that would be amazing if they just
quietly without anybody noticing just
stopped having governments and if nobody
knew everyone would just sort of like
still behave themselves
would that work
well how would you pay the cops and all
that i don't [ __ ] know i guess it
wouldn't work but i'm amazed at how well
it's working with part of the government
shutdown
and i actually saw some quote
heard this woman say on the news that
the federal reserve
is trying to help out
with the misbehaving government and that
was one of the [ __ ] funniest things i
ever heard
um all right and i'm not getting into
all that [ __ ] all right you either know
about it or you don't either agree with
it or you don't and i'm tired of [ __ ]
arguing it
all right
one man thrill ride everybody let's get
to the uh
the letters for this week one man thrill
ride
uh
dear billenstein's monster
i don't get that one is that
frankenstein's
bill billingstein's monster uh fellow
boston area native and ric flair
enthusiast all right so i love this guy
already
um you have to check out this video a
guy recorded it before returning to his
alma mater to play the in the alumni
game it's absolutely electric there's
nothing you
you can come back with after this it's
perfect i wish i could hear patrice's
reaction go [ __ ] yourself oh i guess
that was a youtube video
but jesus christ what a [ __ ] intro
that was i have to watch this
do i have to watch it live
good morning
the one-man thrill ride has arrived to
the campus of fitchburg state university
to relive his glory days at the 2013
fitchburg state baseball university
alumni baseball game i am in the parking
lot right now
hammering a bacon egg and she
hold the chi
in preparation to go deep with four hits
and put on a laser show to the likes of
which you have never witnessed in your
entire life
all right i gotta watch the rest of this
i know it's gonna get better
you get you gotta have the visual of it
this guy this guy's not [ __ ] around
all right i'm going to watch that
how do you not love sports i get it i
get it i can understand why you don't
love it you know why you don't love it
because you're sucked at it but then
you're not good at being a superhero
either but how do you get into that
captain america would totally beat the
[ __ ] out of the hulk because he has that
little sphere with the star on it advice
for young marriage dear bill
i love your stuff yada yada i'm in a
pickle
i married when i was 18 to a 30 year old
woman get out
get out immediately
if you're wired like a man
get out a woman is has more
sophisticated wiring than a man so she
can be 12 years younger
all right
i don't know if they're more
sophisticated but different things
motivate themselves
themselves what am i saying motivate
them all right they're motivated by
different things other than look at the
debts on her
um all right
i don't
all right so when you're 38 she's going
to be 50.
all right and you're gonna walk into the
bedroom
i don't know that's that's uh
maybe i'm not mature enough to do that
why am i superimposing my [ __ ] onto your
[ __ ] why don't i just read what the [ __ ]
you have to say i'm sorry that was a
real selfish moment there
all right this guy's in a pickle i'm
married he says i'm married
i i married when i was 18 to a 30 year
old woman whom i deeply loved i didn't
get to that point i'm already telling
you leave i'm sorry sir anyways he goes
i had low self-esteem then i used to
play
world of warcraft be lazy and have a
beard i am 23 now and i still love my
life but my life has changed i'm fit
clean shaven and more successful
therefore women are showing interest in
me at last my wife is getting older and
i still like her and a lot
like her a lot and find her attract
attractive but the age gap coupled with
her bad pms is starting to affect me
yeah and that's not gonna get better sir
like and she's still young
i already know where i'm gonna go with
this
my wife is kind fun when not having pms
and a good mother oh you have kids
uh oh wait a second dude when i am
around hot 18 to 25 year old women i
feel like i cannot control myself so far
i have controlled myself but i feel like
i'm fighting a losing battle what do i
do my wife has seen the conflict within
me and sympathizes she sometimes says
that i can have some fun with other
women if i tell her first but i don't
know if this is true or if
or is
a honey trap
my i don't know what that means uh my
wife is honest but when emotions get in
the way i don't know how she will behave
do i secretly cheat when i have a good
opportunity to get away with it do i
talk to her about some freedom do i
leave her before the time bomb
implodes explodes sorry or do i knuckle
down and masturbate myself into
submission having lower self-esteem and
missing out on fun but being a better
husband
um
[Music]
oh wow dude i i applaud your honesty uh
listen you have to do what's right for
you at the end of the day i don't know
if you have though are those kids your
kids
i don't know dude
look
i'm not trying to blame her but what
kind of a 30 year old marries an 18 year
old man or woman
all right you're a [ __ ] kid
she's a woman she married a [ __ ]
child i know legally you're a man but
you're not and that goes the same thing
if a guy
a [ __ ] 30 year old man marries an 18
year old like i don't know how that's
[ __ ] legal even though the woman is
legal and she is a woman she's a [ __ ]
child compared to a 30 year old
all right
and just the the mental [ __ ] tennis
that just how much further
those are that's a huge amount of time
in your life all right if you're 50 and
your wife's 38 or you're 50 your
husband's 38 that's a different thing
okay 30 to 18 is huge i mean you're
talking like she's almost twice your
[ __ ] age
12 year gap you've only lived 18 years
what is she three quarters your age come
on you mathletes what is that
all right i don't know what to tell you
if you already have kids with this woman
i don't know what the answer is but if
those are her kids
um you're 23 so you've been married five
she's 35 she still has a chance
she's still young she can still go out
and meet somebody more around her age
um
dude
you got married too young
you got married way too [ __ ] young to
somebody way too old that's what i think
that's just what i think but i don't
have the feelings you have for this
woman all right this is just me on the
outside looking in i am a commitment foe
i am a psycho and i am a piece of [ __ ]
when it comes to [ __ ] women all right
and i've earned that
in spades believe me so
take what i'm saying at a gr with a
grain of [ __ ] salt all right
um
you're talking about a 45 year old guy
who never got married
and [ __ ] up every relationship he was
ever in that's what that's what you're
talking to right here okay
so
i just know what i wanted to do when i
was 23 years old
and i was also on man i mean like
18 to 23 years old you're supposed to be
out there
experiencing being young
and and uh
and all that has to offer that's what
you're supposed in discovering about
yourself okay now however if you
married this woman and you had kids with
her you do have a responsibility and
that's a whole other can of worms and a
can of worms that is not in my life yet
so i don't know how to advise you on
that
right
you know there are some things you you
know some things in life you do miss out
on
and sometimes you get this other great
thing but because of that great thing
you you don't have enough time to enjoy
this other thing
so you might be in that situation if
if you have [ __ ] kids i would say ask
somebody else who has kids ask somebody
else who's in your boat but look if
those are her kids and you got married
at 18 and she's 30
and now you're 23 and she's 35 um
i'm not i don't i don't know what to do
that whole [ __ ]
i don't know what to do uh
i would say get out
i would say get out that's what i would
say i guess that's what i am saying but
i i don't understand whether you have
kids yet i don't know if you have kids
with her and i don't know how
how deep is your love for that woman how
deep he is i don't know you know
i'm i don't have enough information on
that one sir but my gut's saying that
you should uh shove it off the buffalo
i feel you know what i feel
irresponsible on that one i don't know
that i gave you good advice sir i would
ask around more so there's a jump off
point my ignorant thoughts all right
girlfriend wants me to take an std test
jesus christ that one's coming right out
of the gate huh how far are we here
all right
girlfriend wants me you know what before
i do that let me just bang out the last
couple advertising quit you complaining
i got two more here right all right here
we go legal zoom everybody legal zoom a
lot of pride comes along with starting
your own dream business but think about
the stress you'll feel if you don't take
the right steps to legally protect
yourself
and your business personal assets and
all that stuff right from the beginning
that's why i recommend legalzoom.com
during the past 12 years over a million
business owners have trusted legalzoom
to help start their businesses legal
zooms will legal zooms legal zoom will
save you a lot of time and a pile of
money on startup costs plus they provide
solutions to help you run a successful
business legalzoom can provide self-help
services at your specific directions or
connect you with an attorney but they
are not a law firm just go to
legalzoom.com today to see what's right
for you form an llc get a dba
incorporate or form a non-profit all
starting at just 99
plus you'll save even more when you
enter burr b-u-r-r in the referral box
at checkout that's legalzoom.com promo
code burr one more time legalzoom.com
promo code burr
lastly stamps.com
some small companies think leasing oppo
leasing a postage meter is how business
businesses get postage for their letters
and packages but they don't realize that
there's a better way what is that way
say it with me everybody stamps dot com
unlike a postage meter stance.com has no
hidden fees like a meter ink charger or
reset fees no long-term contracts no
extra hardware to buy or lease
stamps.com can save you up to eighty
percent
compared to a postage meter plus with
stamps.com you can do more than you can
with the meter using your existing
address book send tracking information
to recipients with the click of a button
the choice is clear stamps.com offers
more features for a fraction of the cost
you'd have to be a [ __ ] not to try it i
use stance.com to send out all my dvds i
never had a problem i'm an idiot and i
can use it if i can do it you can too
special offer right here use my last
name bur
for a no risk trial plus 110 bonus offer
that includes a digital scale and up to
55 dollars free postage don't wait go to
stamps.com before you do anything else
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in bur bur that
stamps.com enter bur okay
back to the podcast
girlfriend lady wants me to take an std
test
hiya bill all right right there i think
you're from england
don't you guys say that over there hiya
um so
oh by the way i said wales england a
year uh a year ago a couple weeks back
they're separate countries i never knew
i could never to scott scotland its own
country you never because it's great
britain
ireland's fighting it's just [ __ ]
confusing and they don't teach us that
[ __ ] over there so scotland wales
england three different countries there
you go they all share share the same
island
and for some reason they don't go to war
with one another although i don't think
they like each other from what i've
heard england they're the [ __ ]
whales are allegedly having sex with
sheep
and uh scotland i don't know they're
like barrel they don't wear shirts and
they'll beat the [ __ ] they'll headbutt
you no headbutting is is australian i
don't know you don't want to [ __ ] around
you don't [ __ ] around in any of those
countries
according to the movies i've watched
um
anyways let's plow ahead here
so bill i've been going out with this
girl for almost five months and
everything has been great so far we
haven't had sex yet because she's a
virgin
like a virgin
the last couple of times we went out she
wanted she wanted to but we were both
drunk and would just fool around and go
to sleep
i'm waiting until she is ready because i
honestly do care about her ah well
you're a nice fella
um
you're not putting any pressure on her
taking out your [ __ ] [ __ ] and balls
there's being like you know can you help
me out over here
what are you what are you what are you
here for if you're not going to all
right it's been six weeks you know you
don't want to be that guy
but the other day
she dropped a bomb on me
uh she asked me to get tested for stds
before we had sex
all right well that makes sense if
you're going to get into a committed
relationship eventually
you want to remove the latex so you can
get the whole experience
you want to go on the whole ride you
don't want to stand next to the roller
coaster watching it do the loopty loops
do you you want to be on that [ __ ]
um anyways i have had sex with seven
different girls and i always you used to
wear a condom
and i always scrub my dick after
scrubbing your dick after i don't think
that that works
oh wait they tell you to do that right
i don't know
if you know
if something got in you it's already in
you just because you washed the area
where
if you get bit by a rattlesnake and then
you wash the cut does the poison leave
your bloodstream
hi i'm i'm not a doctor and i'm putting
out weird [ __ ] information i should
shut the [ __ ] up
um anyway so he watches he washes his
dick afterwards but not his balls
i've been slapping up against it um she
said that i could have i could have an
std that doesn't affect guys but it
affects girls uh she's talking about hpv
that's what she's saying i he goes i
said that's [ __ ] and told her i
don't want to talk about it anymore
uh jesus christ you were an enlightened
man
and now you've now you went into the
cavemen area and you know what i'm not
judging it because we all do it
you will be impatient
you weren't pressuring her
you were being a goddamn gentleman
and all of a sudden out of nowhere you
took off your top hat and you beat her
with the cane
ah jesus buddy what'd you do that for
all right he goes he goes i don't know
what to do
he's like i don't have an std but
there's a little [ __ ] voice in my
head saying well maybe
uh should i say [ __ ] it and do the test
or not
thanks man much appreciated love you
love your show all right you know the
deal sir even if you wear a condom
there's a chance that you could have
something
and uh hpv for the most part does not
show up i guess in guys for what they
say you don't really notice that you
have it but you can give it to women it
causes them all kinds of problems which
of which i forget what it does to them
because it doesn't concern me and i'm a
selfish [ __ ]
all right
so this is what i would do sir um i
would just go out if you really give a
[ __ ] go out and get tested what's great
about getting tested is when it comes
back and you got nothing
you can take those seven people and
clear them off the board like murder
cases you know if you ever watch the
wire you get to erase them all off
and you don't have it you don't have
that that case load
all right you can close those cases
they're not cold cases anymore you
understand what i'm saying you've only
had sex with seven people according to
you you always wore a condom and you
washed your [ __ ] dick and your balls
there well not your balls just your dick
all right
so
i think you got a pretty good chance
that you're all right and if you're only
seven in this is a great time to get
tested all right because then what's
great is when it comes back and you're
negative you know what you are then
you're what's known as a red shirt
virgin
okay you're in your sophomore year but
you haven't taken any hits if you know
what i mean all right so
then that makes you want to be even more
careful
this is why don't you do this just say
listen i got emotional because i'm
afraid
that even though i've been careful i am
scared that yeah when you have sex with
somebody even when you wear a condom you
can still catch [ __ ]
so
uh tell you what why don't we both go
down and get tested we'll do it together
as a couple i apologize for acting like
a caveman
um
will you forgive me
and there you go then you both go out
you get tested you take her out for a
little [ __ ] uh
creme brulee or whatever the [ __ ] they
like to eat
and then you just sit there waiting
here comes the river
um
and hoping to flop you you [ __ ] win
the hand that's all i can tell you sir
but you know what eventually you're
gonna have to [ __ ] know one way or
another and you're only seven in this is
a great time before you go down that
road and you got 30 40 50 under your
belt and you're just jesus christ
thinking all this [ __ ] that you did
and you're walking into that office with
flop sweat okay you don't want to do it
all right i think it's a great thing to
go out and get tested and i think your
girlfriend's a hundred percent in the
right for asking you to do it i feel
like your behavior afterwards was
immature but understandable and you need
to make things right all right go do
your thing man up okay
bully i can beat up
all right
well if there's a bully you can beat up
he's not really a bully
he's just an [ __ ] right hey billy boy
i'm a 15 year old lad from australia and
here's my problem there is a complete
[ __ ] at my school that always picks
on me but here's here's a twist i could
smash the [ __ ] out of this prick
i'm 182 centimeters that's six feet tall
15 years old six feet tall he goes
74 kilograms that's 160 pounds few
people keeping score and every other day
oh and he's about five eight
and weighs about 185 pounds all right so
he's got he's got your bike
he's got you by 25 pounds
but you have the reach advantage this is
the tail of the tape here i love this
you got a four inch reach advantage
unless he has those [ __ ] kevin mchale
arms that are almost dragging on the
ground
all right you go i lift weights every
other day and he's just fat
all right
you're definitely the favorite so far he
goes but this isn't the biggest reason
why i could smash this [ __ ] i have about
20 years of martial arts experience
wait a minute
you're 15 years old how do you have 20
years of experience
oh he's going to break it down i have
about 20 years of martial arts
experience when you add it all up i have
seven years in karate five years in muay
thai
oh jesus dude you bring those [ __ ]
knees to that fat belly
oh my god probably got shins like a
[ __ ] street pole
um
street pole stop sign whatever the [ __ ]
i was trying to say
just i pictured a telephone pole and a
stop sign made out of metal and i came
up with street pole look at that i'm
inventing words here seven years of
karate five years of muay thai five
years
of brazilian jiu jitsu jesus christ
standing up go to the ground what do you
want to do in three years of mma
he constantly calls me name like gay boy
and poof and he slaps me in the back of
the head every day dude you can't have
that
uh this has been happening for like two
months now and i haven't fought back
because i'm worried about getting in
trouble from teachers at my martial arts
classes any advice is welcome
uh thanks for whatever whatever helps
you uh whatever help you can give me
uh go [ __ ] yourself and have a good day
all right sorry well this is the deal
you could sir if you actually applied
what you know you could seriously hurt
this guy but you do have to defend
yourself so is there a way
that the next time he goes to slap you
in the head you can put him in one of
those [ __ ]
those holds where you're just holding
the person's thumb and they're all of a
sudden on their tiptoes going all right
all right all right all right all right
is there a way to just shoot one across
the bow
that's what i'm suggesting i'm not
saying that you [ __ ] this kid up and
then ruined your standing with uh your
uh your seafoods your senseis your your
your
pastors whatever the [ __ ] you call them
down at the dojo
um
yeah but you there's no reason for you
to go to school and get slapped in the
back of the head and being called names
okay so
what i would do is uh
oh what what the [ __ ] you asking me this
is what you do jesus christ here's your
solution talk to one of you your karate
masters there
and just say listen this is the deal i
know after everything that you've taught
me that i could just mop the floor with
this fat tub of [ __ ]
but i don't want to get you know bad
standing with you what what do i do here
have them
have them tell you what to do
because they'll they could probably
suggest
they know the name or whatever that
[ __ ]
how to choke out somebody's thumb
whatever that thing is that you guys do
that i wish i knew how to do um
but here's the deal one way or another
uh
there has to be a solution with this guy
slapping you they're slapping you in the
back of the [ __ ] head
um
do you know how to do a death grip yet
did they taught you that is that an
actual thing why don't you do a double
death grip to his man tits and twist
them before he has a chance to slap you
in the head
don't listen to anything that i'm going
to suggest here
uh why don't you take some twinkies
what could you do with the twinkie and a
martial art thing why don't you make
some nunchuck twinkies
and instead so instead of slapping him
in the face with the with a piece of
wood it's a it's a twinkie and it goes
across his face he's humiliated plus you
know he's a fatty so he's going to have
to lick it off his face and he'll get
into that sugar rush
and his eyes will roll in the back of
his head and by the time his eyes come
back down you're going to be across the
room and he can't slap you in the head i
know there's got to be something
there's got to be something to do
i mean at this point if you don't want
to go physical i would just go verbal
i i you know he's calling you gay boy
and poof i mean why don't you just talk
about his fat tits
just uh just be yes just be really
sincere just be like just out of
curiosity how much do your tits weigh
you know do you wear a sports bra or are
you gonna kind of go with the uh
the giant pocket tea
and the fact that you're already this
fat at our young age like how fat do you
think you're gonna be when you're 40.
these are just questions sir
you know and then when he charges you
like a rhino
just step out of the way and he won't be
able to slow down and he'll maybe go
flying into some desks
i don't know sir
but can you please tell me how this i i
would go
i would go to your uh your dojo masters
there whatever and i'd ask them what to
do but there's no [ __ ] way on any
level that you should have to tolerate
that um
you know
i would do that
ah jesus are they gonna go even really
more mature well i think you should talk
to your teachers about it and then you
become the [ __ ] guy ratted it out
you know it's like that selection that's
like this uh solutions they come up to
on like the view
you just turn around you just they stop
doing that i i i'm not going to tolerate
this
you know
i'd give you like a rape whistle or
something
i don't [ __ ] know i don't know sir
but please let me know how that
works out because it's bothering me that
that dude is doing that to you all right
i don't like bullies
um
ah jesus christ dude uh
you know what i really want to tell you
to do and i'm not gonna all right
divorce settlement
uh divorce settlement cheat uh
dear mr burr i call you mr burr because
i don't know you personally please tell
me if i'm a piece of [ __ ] for doing what
i thought was right i will give you a
quick summary fell in love with high
school sweetheart oh that's tremendous
got married good for you rented a house
awesome ten-year relationship wonderful
two years of marriage cool no kids all
right
came home to our town after a weekend
with my friends in austin to change
locks to our house
knocked on the door for an hour
cops called on me cops say the woman in
the house says we are separated
but married and i have been bothering
her by visiting her
her rented house too much
oh my god
when she opened the door a guy in his
boxers and socks came walking down the
stairs
as the door was opened i didn't see this
coming oh my god i own a couple pawn
shops my dad left me
my dad left me with one and then i grew
it into multiple locations i knew the
relationship was over but we weren't
divorced yet and i didn't want her
taking half of my [ __ ] so i sold my
company locations to my parents for one
dollar for tax reasons
that sounds like a good move i then
bought back the company for full money
in my personal account we've always had
separate accounts then i sold the
company locations back to my parents for
a dollar
i think somehow i think
somehow got demoted from the
new owners
oh you left out a word i think i somehow
got demoted from the new owners
from owner area supervisor to pawn
broker which doesn't make much money at
all this took me about three months to
arrange that doesn't make sense dude
then i sold the company locations back
to my parents for a dollar
so you sold it for a dollar you bought
it back and then you sold it again and
you bought it back with your own money i
need a i need to be a lawyer to
understand this
and he goes i think i somehow got
demoted from the new owners
from owner area supervisor to pawn
broker which doesn't make much money at
all this took me about three months to
arrange all this so i acted like i was
trying to work it out
so that she wouldn't want to divorce yet
needless to say after it was all said
and done she thought that she was going
to get a hefty
amount of money
when i actually think it was a pretty
fair split do you think i did
what i did was [ __ ] up
also i kind of found a way around the
divorce settlement which is an old thing
you brought up but still i'd like your
opinion
um
okay a loyal fan who says [ __ ] those
[ __ ] who follow you for 15 years and
give up on you oh thank you um
no i think what you did was genius
you know
um
the way that she went about getting this
divorce
and calling the cops on you and then
that's on your record that i mean that
was
she
she kind of established the playing
field
you know what i mean it's one of those
knife to a gun fight things she
established the playing field
and um
and you played the game accordingly i
mean i think the fact that you guys both
seems like he got married young
maybe she just didn't know how to break
up with you in a more of a mature way
so
she kind of broke up with you mentally
stayed with you begun another
relationship and then just
when you went away just dropped the
hammer and tried to do a one
like a one stop thing locks are gone
he's bugging me this is the guy i'm
[ __ ] see ya and you you get all that
information in 90 seconds um
whatever so then you make sure she
doesn't get the pawn shops i i don't
know
i think that's pretty fair it sounds
like she's young enough to build up her
own empire and with the cold calculated
way that she dealt with cutting you out
of her life i think she's going to do
great in the corporate world so she'll
be fine so [ __ ] it you did the right
thing good for you
good for you all right wrap up for the
show here
all right that's it that's it for the
podcast by the way um i want to thank
everybody who's been listening the
listenership has been steadily climbing
up
and um
and everybody who's been coming out to
my shows
um i i got to tell you i'm having more
fun
than i i've ever had on stage in my life
and i really feel like i'm going through
this growth period i've been pushing
myself this
these things i've these few things i've
been trying to work on
in my act
and uh it's like the it's been like a
three year process and i feel like i'm
pushing through right now
and uh so i just i don't know i feed off
the crowds when you guys show up it's
really been helping to push me so i just
wanted to say actually something nice
for for once on the podcast so thank you
um and i'm off the road here after six
weeks in a row on the road i'm off for
the next two three weeks
so i'm gonna be going around la trying
to work on some stuff
re-uh recharge my batteries here
juice do some yoga do some pull-ups
climb the rope
uh
whatever the [ __ ] i'm gonna do watch
some football watch some hockey and that
type of [ __ ] i'm gonna chill out here
for a few weeks
and uh anyways that's the podcast for
this week uh my next show is coming up
believe it or not are not until november
all right and uh i got a run of shows
coming up
for um
i'm doing dc new york city
philadelphia
i don't have the exact dates these are
all on my website and then i also am
going to be doing
i'm making up the last bit of the red
state tour dates
uh i'm doing deadwood south dakota
tulsa oklahoma
and uh wichita kansas
and uh that's gonna be the last of it
so i make those up is there anything
else i'm doing there
i don't know all i know is i'm thinking
of going to deadwood a day early
in fact i know i'm going to go because i
want to see some stuff when i'm out
there
and uh and then i'm going to leave early
the next day before oklahoma because uh
the sooners have a game that day i'm
gonna try to make it unless the flex
schedule makes it an eight o'clock game
and uh and i don't know what the [ __ ]
i'm gonna do in kansas
other than i'm not gonna say hey we're
not in kansas anymore and look around
and have everybody [ __ ] roll their
eyes like they haven't seen that 58 i
mean heard it 58 times a [ __ ] day
from taurus all right i'm babbling here
that's the end of the show um
now that the show's over don't forget to
sign up for your free trial of hulu plus
once again hulu plus lets you binge on
thousands of hit tv shows anytime
anywhere on your tv pc smartphone or
tablet you never have to miss a show
again with your busy schedule it's the
perfect way to consume television these
days or movies whatever you want to do
support this podcast and get an extended
free trial of hulu plus when you go to
the podcast page at billboard.com and
click on the hulu plus banner or go to
huluplus.com bill that's hulupus.com
bill
that's the podcast go [ __ ] yourselves
um i will see you guys in dc new york
and philly
in a month
and uh i'm home for the whole month i'm
psyched gonna make another [ __ ]
pumpkin pie and [ __ ] get ready for
halloween all right that's it
i'll talk to you later
you